du jour appelle la discussion de la
proposition de loi visant à renforcer le
le rôle des maires dans l'attribution
des logements sociaux présentés par la
présidente Sophie prima et plusieurs de
ses collègues à la demande du groupe les
République dans la discussion générale
la parole est à la présidente Sophie
prima auteur de la proposition de loi
pour 10
[Applaudissements]
minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
madame la Présidente de commission et
rapporteur cher Dominique dans un
premier temps mes chers collègues
permettez-moi de saluer la première
journée de présidence de notre collègue
Mathieu Darnaud à qui je souhaite le
plus grand succès dans sa
mission je souhaite également remercier
Bruno rotillot le président de notre
groupe groupe qui a inscrit cette
proposition de loi comme premier texte
examiné dans cette session et les 85
cosignataire de cette proposition de loi
c'est la reconnaissance de l'importance
du sujet que nous portons depuis des
mois j'allais dire voire des années et
qui s'est révélé peut-être plus encore
pendant les désordres du de juin dernier
et qui attrait à ce que l'on appelle peu
élégamment le peuplement de nos communes
je veux également remercier Dominique
Estrosi Sasson qui a accepté d'être la
rapporte de cette proposition de loi
certes sur un sujet qu'elle connaît bien
mais dans un délai de temps vraiment
très restreint pour commencer mon propos
mes chers collègues je voudrais vous
dire tout ce que ce texte n'est pas ce
texte n'est pas l'alpha et l'oméga d'une
réforme de fond du logement que nous
attendons avec une vraie impatience
puisque la la crise qui touche
durablement ce secteur économique n'a
rien d'un hasard elle est le fruit des
décisions prises depuis 6 ans en silo en
matière de fiscalité de suppression de
recettes pour les communes elle est le
fruit de la RLS de la politique
d'attribution de la descente aux enfers
du peuplement de certains quartiers de
la montée des normes de construction et
donc du coût de construction de la
raréfaction du foncier par nature
inflationniste de la hausse des taux
d'intérêt et le Sénat alerte alerte
alerte depuis des années et donc oui
nous avons hâte de travailler sur ces
sujets et non ce texte n'est pas la
solution à la crise du logement
ce n'est pas non plus une réponse aux
Herm de la politique de la de la ville
dénoncé dans plusieurs rapports
transpartisans de cette assemblée et à
ces zonages politiques de la ville qui
ne correspondent plus à la réalité de
nos territoires mais qui correspondent à
des impératifs budgétaire de l'État
année après année vous restraignez les
moyens des communes qui ont de plus en
plus de mal à accompagner les plus
modestes de leurs administré ce texte
n'est pas non plus enfin je l'espère le
grand acte de des centralisation de la
politique de du logement promis une fois
encore par le Président de la République
et qui hypothétiquement arrivera quelque
part l'année prochaine ce texte n'est
pas non plus le retour comme je l'ai
entendu d'un clientélisme local reproche
fait parfois par ceux qui n'ont jamais
présidé la moindre commission
d'attribution des logements ou assumer
la responsabilité locale celle de gérer
comme un horloger les équilibres dans
nos communes ce texte n'est pas et
sûrement pas la possibilité de donner
aux maires la la possibilité de refuser
tous les dossiers difficiles car les
maires mes chers collègues ont le sens
des responsabilités et ils prennent
chacun leur part des difficultés des
Français dans mon département l'exemple
de montigi le Bretonneux dans les
ivelines le démontre parfaitement depuis
que la communauté d'aglomération de
Saint-Quentin en Yveline donne une voix
prépondérante au Mair la commune
accueille plus que sa part de famille
fragile j'ai même entendu qu'une
sélection par le nom serait possible
alors mes chers collègues moi qui été
maire d'une commune que j'habite depuis
plus de 60 ans qui compte plus de 40 %
de logements sociaux qui habite cette
valete de Scine dans laquelle la
diversité d'origine est une réalité
depuis des décennies au-delà des
discours je suis outrée par ces propos
et de cette défiance vis-à-vis des mares
alors qu'est-ce que ce texte ce texte
est un premier pas modeste mais urgent
un premier pas vers une décentralisation
que nous appelons de nos vœux que les
élus appellent de leur vœux et même que
les bailleurs appellent de leurs vœux
public ou privés ce texte s'est redonné
au maires et à leurs adjoints la
responsabilité pleine et entière de la
qualité de vie et de la bonne
intégration de toutes les populations y
compris et surtout des populations
modestes c'est préféré l'intelligence
territoriale des élus locaux et des
services sociaux des communes à celle
des algorithmes ou des considérations
financières des bailleurs combien
d'idioe voyons-nous dans nos communes
dans nos quartiers des personnes à
mobilité réduite à qui l'on attribue un
logement au second étage sans ascenseurs
des couples qui travaillent à deux ou 3
heures de transport de leur logement qui
arrivent déracinés de leur environnement
et qui finiront soit par lâcher leur
travail par épuisement soit seront dans
l'incapacité de s'occuper de leurs
enfants et à qui d'ailleurs on le
reprochera plus tard ce texte qui fait
confiance au maire c'est s'assurer enfin
que chaque famille reçue sera bien
intégrée dans un immeuble dans un
quartier dans un environnement favorable
garant de la véritable mixité pas de la
mixité théorique pas celle de Twitter ou
des plateaux télé dont certains ont
plein la bouche mais de la vraie mixité
d'âge de niveaux sociaux d'éducation de
structure familial c'est s'assurer que
l'on ne met pas de la misère sur la
misère des turbulents avec d'autres
turbulents et çaass assurer ainsi de la
structuration des quartiers et de leur
tranquillité ce texte c'est aussi aider
les maires à convaincre les habitants
parfois rétrissant que construire du
logement social sert à aider ceux des
habitants de la commune ou des alentours
qui cherchent un logement soit parce que
la famille habite là soit parce que les
personnes travaillent à proximité
comment faire comprendre à nos habitants
que l'on construit du logement social
qui ne sera pas destiné d'abord à ceux
qui on en besoin localement al alors
j'ai entendu a tout aussi je l'ai déjà
dit c'est le retour du clientélisme mais
mes chers collègues si le CL
clientélisme c'est attribué à un
logement social un enfant de la commune
qui souhaite y rester je l'assume car
nos quartiers ce sont aussi des
relations familiales amicales des
relations de solidarité des attachements
à une commune dans laquelle on a grandi
qui sont autre chose que de trouver un
toit si le clientélisme c'est donner un
logement aux personnes qui travaillent
sur le territoire aux adsèes de nos
écoles aux infirmières de nos hôpitaux
aux agents de police et de gendarmerie
de notre département alors je l'assume
et ne me parlez pas des priorités de la
loi et ses ru elles sont si nombreuses
qu'elles n'ont plus de sens mes chers
collègues que voyons-nous depuis l'ribu
que l'attribution n'est plus faites par
les maires des quartiers qui se
déstructurent qui se déshumanisent
lentement mais sûrement qui parfois se
déséquilibrent se concentrre sur ceux
qui sont de plus en plus en difficulté
qui s'électrise et croyez-moi je sais
que c'est une réalité y compris dans ma
propre commune et nos compatriotes en
rendent responsables les maires et ça ce
n'est plus possible les maires veulent
bien assumer de construire des logements
sociaux et ne vous arrêtez pas au
quelques contres exemples caricaturaux
attachez-vous aux centaines de MRES de
bonne volonté ils veulent bien
évidemment prendre leur part des cas les
plus difficiles mais ils veulent avoir
la pleine responsabilité de l'équilibre
de leur commune du peuplement de leur
quartier qu'ils connaissent mieux que
toutes les céol et tous les algorithmes
mes chers collègues ce premier pas est
une étape fondamentale ce texte n'est
pas la solution unique aux événements
que nous avons connu en juin mais il en
est un élément faites confiance au Mair
aux adjoints au Mair au servic des
villes qui font du travail de dentelle
cage d'escalier par cage d'escalier
microquartier par microquartier famille
par famille et répondez à l'engagement
fait par le Président de la République
lui-même au présid id du Sénat le 3
juillet dernier et aux maires qui ont
connu des émeutes le 4 juillet sans
attendre le grand soir du logement
merci merci la parole est à la
présidente Dominique estr Sasson
rapporteur de la commission des affaires
économiques pour 10
[Applaudissements]
minutes monsieur le Président Madame
ministre mes chers collègues la
commission des affaires économiques a
approuvé la proposition de loi déposée
par notre collègue Sophie prima visant à
renforcer le rôle des maires dans
l'attribution des logements sociaux elle
a même décidé de renforcer les
prérogatives des mairres en la matière
avant de vous présenter les évolutions
souhaitées par notre commission et de
répondre à certaines critiques qui ont
été formulé je voudrais revenir sur le
diagnostic largement partagé qui
nécessite une intervention législative
aujourd'hui quel est ce constat les
maires ont un rôle central dans le
développement du logement social à
travers les permis de construire
l'apport de terrain ou de financement et
la garantie des emprunts mais cette
centralité ne leur est pas reconnue dans
l'attribution des logements qui leur
échappent majoritairement nombreux sont
ceux qui déplorent désormais un
véritable sentiment de dépossession des
maires vis-à-vis du logement social ce
qui fragilise leur volonté d'en
construire de nouveau cette défiance est
également palpable parmi nos concitoyens
affaiblissant d'autant plus
l'acceptation de nouveau programmes de
logement cette perception est alimentée
par au moins quatre facteurs
premièrement la pénurie de logements
sociaux face à une demande croissante
alors que le parcours résidentiel est
complètement bloqué deuxièmement la
montée en puissance de politiques
publiques conduisant à des relogements
prioritaire comme le renouvellement
urbain la politique du logement d'abord
ou du droit au logement opposable d'Allo
qui préempte le peu de logements
disponibl parfois au détriment des
demandeurs de la commune où ils sont
situés troisièmement la très grande
complexité de la gestion en flux et de
la cotation des de demande qui vont
entrer en vigueur fin 2023 et qui
suscitent inquiétude et incompréhension
et enfin la montée en puissance des
intercommunalités qui contribue à
complexifier les modalités de la
décision ces constats ont été corroborés
par les émeutes de l'été le président de
la République madame la ministre
n'a-t-il pas déclaré devant les 220
maires qu'il recevait le 25 juin dernier
à l'Élysée vouloir travailler
sur les attributions de logements
sociaux afin de laisser une plus grande
marge de manœuvre au maires et de leur
donner une meilleure maîtrise du
peuplement de leur commune la
proposition de loi que nous examinons
aujourd'hui à l'initiative de madame
Sophie prima que je remercie très
sincèrement et du groupe les
républicains qui l'a inscrite en
priorité identifie parfaitement les l'un
des nœuds du problème à savoir la
marginalisation des maire dans les
commissions d'attribution ils sont seuls
parmi aujourd'hui une douzaine de
membres notre commission a donc
travailler à trouver la meilleure
solution pour y remédier en concertation
avec des associations d'élus le
mouvement HLM et avec les services du
ministère du Logement la Commission a
retenu trois leviers pour redonner la
main au maire premier levier la
présidence de la commission
d'attribution des logements sociaux par
le maire de la commune ou par le
président de
l'intercommunalité lorsque celle-ci est
intercommunale c'est logique et c'est
cohérent puisque les intercommunalités
sont les chefs de fil de la politique de
l'habitat comme gestionnaire du bassin
de vie deuxème levier la création d'un
droit de veto du maire sur une
attribution donnée ce droit de de veto
sera bien évidemment motivé et
s'inscrira dans le droit existant trème
levier la généralisation du contingent
de l'État au maire lors de la première
attribution d'un programme neuf lui
permettant ainsi d'avoir directement à
sa main la moitié des logements à
attribuer cette faculté est déjà permise
par le droit actuel et elle est mise en
œuvre d'ailleurs dans certains
territoires mais elle n'est pas aussi
connue et utilisé qu'elle ne devrait
l'être cette mesure redonnera donc une
vraie capacité au maire de maîtriser le
peuplement mais cela me paraît également
de nature à soutenir la construction de
nouveaux logements sociaux et
l'application de la loi SRU en
permettant de répondre à la demande
locale et donc de légitimer ce type de
construction face aux critiques
récurrentes que nous connaissons je
voudrais enfin répondre à trois
critiques principales formulé contre ce
texte la première est de ne pas apporter
de solution à la pénurie de ement
sociaux et donc à la crise du logement
j'y souscris bien volontiers vous le
savez j'ai toujours été ici en première
ligne pour dénoncer les coupes claires
du gouvernement contre le logement et
contre le logement social en particulier
la pénurie que nous constatons
aujourd'hui elle est directement liée à
la politique qui est menée par Emmanuel
Macron depuis 2017 dont les bailleurs
sociaux ont été les premières victimes
avec la RLS et avec un peu plus d'un
milliard par an de EUR en plus beaucoup
de logements à cause de cette politique
ne sont pas sortis de terre aujourd'hui
mais ce n'est pas l'objet du texte dont
nous débattons aujourd'hui je pense
néanmoins qu'il contribuera à débloquer
des dossiers de construction de
logements sociaux en redonnant cette
confiance au maire le second reproche
qui est fait à ce texte est de ne pas
être une réponse suffisante aux émeutes
de l'été dernier là aussi je reprends
volontiers la critique ce texte n'a
nulement la prétention de résoudre un
problème au combien complexe et profond
comme celui des quartiers prioritaires
et plus généralement de l'intégration
c'est juste un élément qui doit
permettre d'avancer dans la bonne
direction nous l'avions d'ailleurs
indiqué dans le rapport d'évaluation de
la politique de la ville que nous avons
publié à l'été 2022 avec Vivian
Artigalas et Valérie lettard enfin
certains comme l'a souligné encore
Sophie prima font le reproche à ce texte
de rétablir le clientélisme voire de
permettre une discrimination des
demandeurs en fonction de leur origine
ou de leur nom sur des critères qui ne
seraient non républicains je trouve ce
soupçon aussi insultant que blessant
vis-à-vis des
maires gardons-nous des anathèmes
peut-on reprocher à un maire de vouloir
loger ses habitants à commencé par les
ménages d'Allo déjà installé sur sa
commune je ne le crois pas je tiens à
souligner qu'il n'y a absolument aucune
ambigué dans ce texte il renforce la
capacité du maire à décider mais le
maire devra bien évidemment appliquer la
loi la proposition de loi de Sophie
prima ne vient pas modifier les règles
définissant les publics prioritaires
découlant de la mise en œuvre du droit
au logement opposable ou encore de la
future mise en œuvre de la gestion en
flux et de la cotation des demandes de
logement si le maire utilise son droit
de vetto il le fera désormais sur une
base légale concrètement il le fera sur
la base du travail de qualification du
parc social et de son occupation qui a
été réalisée par les bailleurs sociaux
en concertation avec les élus au niveau
intercommunal et qui vise à identifier
les résidences disposant de capacités
d'accueil et celles qui sont plus
fragiles et qui ont besoin de
stabilisation l'ushh l'Union Sociale de
l'habitat a édité un document de
référence et de cadrage qui identifie
une cinquantaine de critères objectifs
et qui sont des critères tout à fait
républicain ce travail d'identification
a notamment été mené dans des
intercommunalités comme valencienne
limog Grenoble pleain commune ou boucle
nord de sè en région parisienne tout
tout parfaitement républicaine me
semble-t-il nous le savons tous nombre
de difficultés s'explique par la
concentration des publics fragiles dans
les mêmes résidences pour réussir la
mixité sociale il faut autant accueillir
des ménages fragiles que dans d'autres
cas favoriser des ménages pouvant
apporter une réelle stabilité à une
résidence ou à un quartier monsieur le
Président Madame la ministre mes chers
collègues
c'est bien dans cet état d'esprit que la
commission des affaires économiques a
travaillé en souhaitant permettre à
travers ce texte non seulement de
redonner la main au maire sur les
attributions mais surtout de les
conforter dans leur rôle central de
garant du bien vivre ensemble dans leur
commune et de l'accès au logement c'est
ce que nos citoyens attendent merci
beaucoup merci la parole est à Madame
Dominique fort ministre délégué chargé
des collectivités territoriales et de la
ruralité merci monsieur le président
madame la Présidente Sophie prima madame
la rapporteur Dominique Estrosi sassonne
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs vous
l'avez rappelé madame la sénatrice
madame la rapporteur le 4 juillet
dernier le président de la République
recevait les élus locaux des communes
les plus touchées par les violences
urbaines à cette occasion il prenait
huit engagements qui font depuis l'objet
d'un suivi resserré par la première
ministre et les ministres concernés
c'est le sens d'ailleurs du Conseil
national de la refondation consacré aux
suites données aux violences urbaines
qui s'est tenu la semaine dernière parmi
ces engagements l'un d'entre eux visait
à confier les attributions des logements
sociaux au maire dans une logique de
responsabilisation accrue afin de mieux
comprendre les enjeux afférants à cet
engagement il convient de rappeler en
premier lieu que le dispositif
d'attribution de sociaux fait l'objet
d'un encadrement législatif et
réglementaire particulièrement développé
et détaillé l'empilement successif des
textes sur le sujet peut d'ailleurs en
rendre la lecture parfois complexe même
pour les initiés toutfois convient de
garder à l'esprit que les attributions
de logements sociaux qui s'inscrivent
dans le respect de la vocation
généraliste du parc social en France
doivent concilier à la fois la recherche
de mixité sociale en particulier dans
les les quartiers politiques de la ville
et certaines résidences confrontées à
une précarité croissante de leurs
occupants et l'accès au logement pour
les publics prioritaires au premierers
rang desquels figurent les ménages
bénéficiant d'une reconnaissance du
droit au logement opposable le dalallo
sans oublier les sortants d'hébergement
et autres ménages définis comme
prioritaires par le code de la
construction et de l'habitation par les
accords collectifs départementaux et par
les conventions intercommunales
d'attribution des logements l'État et
les bailleurs sociaux sont responsables
de l'atteinte des objectifs en matière
d'accueil des plus défavorisés et
peuvent être sanctionné en cas de
manquement à cette atteinte d'autre part
pour avoir une bonne compréhension des
possibilités et limite des dispositifs
d'attribution il est nécessaire de
préciser que les attributions
s'organisent à trois niveaux le premier
niveau concerne l'inscription des
demandeurs de logement social et les
conditions d'éligibilité des ménages au
logement social le second niveau
concerne les réservataires de logements
sociaux les réservataires qui regroupent
principalement les collectivités locales
l'État et Action Logement disposant en
contrepartie de leurs apports financiers
ou de l'ctroit de garantie de prêt sont
responsables de la désignation des
candidats pour l'attribution des
logements qui leur sont réservés en
règle générale sauf cas particulier des
publics prioritaires ils doivent
présenter au moins trois candidatures
pour un même logement le troème niveau
concerne enfin la décision d'attribution
ou de non attribution voir le refus
d'attribution ces décisions constituent
les prérogatives essentielles de la
commission d'attribution et d'occupation
des logements caléol qui réunit outre
des représentants du bailleur social le
maire le préfet et le président de le
PCI dans ces conditions vous comprendrez
aisément que toute réforme des
attributions ne peut s'envisager sans
réfléchir à ses conséquences sur les
deux objectifs majeurs de la politique
d'attribution évoqué plus haut ni à sa
mise en œuvre opérationnelle concrète
aux différents maillons de la chaîne
d'attribution que je viens de rappeler
l'engagement du président doit donc
s'apprécier à l'ône de ces objectifs et
de cette organisation alors donner plus
de pouvoir au maires dans les
attributions c'est d'abord leur
permettre de faciliter la mixité sociale
qui mieux qu'un élu local un maire peut
connaître finement immeuble par immeuble
les enjeux de peuplement et ces enjeux
de logement et d'habitat pour éviter
d'aggraver les difficultés éventuelles
qui peuvent
exister donner plus de pouvoir aux
maires dans les attributions c'est
également les responsabiliser sur le
logement plus défavorisé principalement
en dehors des quartiers politiques de la
ville et des résidences à enjeu de
mixité sociale il ne peut pas y avoir de
politiques d'attribution juste et
solidaire sans cette mobilisation pour
l'accès au logement des plus modestes
prioritairement dans les lieux qui ne
qui ne concentrent pas déjà des ménages
en sit situation précaire à ce titre
nous devons reconnaître que les
dispositifs existants en la matière
notamment ceux créés en 2017 ne
fonctionne pas la loi égalité
citoyenneté n'a pas permis d'inverser
les tendances observées les sanctions ne
sont pas une solution et la
responsabilité reste trop diluée la
responsabilisation proposée par le
Président de la République dans une
logique de gagnant gagnant doit
justement permettre qu'en parallèle de
la mixité sociale les plus défavorisé
soit aussi logé en dehors des quartiers
déjà fragiles enfin donner plus de
pouvoirs au Mair dans les attributions
va faciliter la production de nouveaux
logements sociaux dès lors que les élus
locaux seront davantage décisionnaires
ils pourront aussi plus facilement
accepter voir encourager le
développement de programmes de logements
sociaux au service des besoins de leur
territoire le gouvernement a donc déjà
commencé à travailler pour concrétiser
cet engagement dans le cadre des travaux
engagés sur la décentralisation pour
lesqueles nous souhaitons présenter un
projet de loi au printemps 2024 ces
travaux doivent permettre d'adopter
l'approche global nécessaire à la mise
en œuvre de politiqu d'attribution
répondant aux différents enjeux que je
viens d'expliciter ils doivent
contribuer à simplifier les procédures
et dispositifs existants jugés par tous
trop complexes et finalement peu
efficace ils doivent surtout mieux
répartir les pouvoirs et les
responsabilités de manière à confier aux
collectivités locales les moyens et les
obligations associés à la atteinte des
objectifs en matière d'attribution de
logements sociaux dans le respect de
l'égalité des droits et des
citoyens ce n'est que cette logique
globale qui permettra ensuite
conformément au souhait du président de
la République une clarification des
lieux de prise de décision et une juste
responsabilisation des acteurs publics
c'est la raison pour laquelle la
proposition de loi quiil est proposée
d'examiner aujourd'hui relative au rôle
des maires dans les attributions de
logements sociaux nous paraît légèrement
incomplète du fait qu'elle ne s'attaque
à un des les éléments de la chaîne
d'attribution et qu'elle vise
essentiellement à conférer de nouveaux
droits au maire sans les responsabilités
associées pour autant cette proposition
de loi que nous
examinons pour autant cette proposition
de loi que nous examinons aujourd'hui
permet d'initier cette discussion
ensemble porté par le groupe les
républicains elle a fait l'objet d'un
travail important de la commission des
affaires économiques dont je salue et
félicite la nouvelle présidente
Dominique Estrosi Sasson elle est aussi
la rapporteur de cette proposition de
loi issu du passage en Commission le
texte a déjà considérablement évolué en
particulier je note que la Commission
privilégie un pouvoir d'opposition du
maire à l'attribution d'un logement un
ménage plutôt qu'une hausse des droits
de vote au profit de la commune par
l'augmentation du nombre de
représentants siégeant siégeant dans les
commissions d'attribution la Commission
a aussi souhaité automatiser la
délégation du contingent préfectoral
auprès des maires lors de la première
mise en location des des nouvelles
résidences nous partageons avec les
sénateurs la volonté d' avancer ensemble
sur ce sujet des attributions en lien
avec le projet plus global du
gouvernement de décentraliser un certain
nombre de leviers de la politique du
logement et de l'habitat aux
collectivités locales au-delà de la
légère réserve que j'ai exprimé
concernant la nécessité de disposer
d'une approche globale permettant de
lier ce sujet à d'autres enjeux de la
décentralisation mais vous l'avez dit
madame la Présidente tel que la
programmation des logements sociaux la
politique de loyers des bailleurs
sociaux les attributions de logement
sociaux au ménag prioritaire nous
souhaitons bien sûr travailler le texte
présenté en premier lieu permettez-moi
de rappeler les droits dont disposeent
d'ors et déjà les maire dans les
commissions d'attribution de logements
sociaux ils en sont membres de droit et
disposent d'une voix prépondérante en
cas de partage des voix dans les
quartiers politiques de la ville ils
peuvent demander la mise en place d'une
commission interbailleur et
interréservataire chargé de désigner les
candidats pour les logements attribués
en cas d'échec d'une attribution de
logement social ils peuvent en outre
présenter un C candidat
enfin parce qu'ils
apportent des garanties aux emprunts
voire des subventions ces mèes disposent
de droits de réservation dans les
programmes variant suivant les
situations locales de 20 à 50 % des
logements ils ont donc déjà un impact
non négligeable sur le peuplement des
résidences à travers cette capacité à
proposer des candidats sur une partie
des logements la proposition de loi que
vous pter propose d'aller plus loin dans
les pouvoirs octroyés au maire en
premier lieu le Gouvernement est
favorable à votre proposition prévoyant
que le maire dispose d'un pouvoir
d'opposition à une proposition
d'attribution et de la possibilité de
demander la non attribution d'un
logement social cette proposition nous
semble préférable aux hypothèses
d'accroissement du nombre de
représentants de la commune au caléol
peu crédiible dans la pratique au vu des
difficultés rencontrées par les
bailleurs pour disposer d'un
représentant à chaque Caléo et les
problèmes éventuels de Corum néanmoins
le pouvoir d'opposition du maire s'il
n'est pas encadré peut soulever des
difficultés peut générer de la vacance
locative en cas de refus répété ce qui
aurait un impact défavorable sur la
situation financière des bailleurs
sociaux sans compter d'éventuelles
risque de squat sur les logements vacans
sur le terrain et surtout une
incompréhension de nos concitoyens alors
que la pression n'a jamais été aussi
forte sur le parc locatif social il
importe que les éventuelles oppositions
puissent être justifié vous avait
indiqué elles seront motivées en
particulier auprès du réservataire qui a
présenté le candidat et qui bien qu'il
participe à la caléole n'y dispose pas
de droit de
vote le gouvernement propose donc deux
amendements visant à surmonter ces
difficultés de manière à créer un
pouvoir d'opposition efficace qui permet
de travailler avec les réservataires de
logement sociaux sur des propositions
plus adaptées au logement proposés nous
vous proposons ainsi de limiter les
l'exercice de ce droit de véto à une
attribution par logement en contrepartie
de l'organisation d'une concertation
préalable à la mise en location des
programme entre le maire le bailleur
social et les réservataires à même de
définir en amont des caléol des
orientations en matière de peuplement le
gouvernement est en effet favorable au
dialogue local dans le cadre des mises
en service de nouveaux immeubles de
logements sociaux ce sont en effet des
moments de peuplement très stratégi qui
peuvent être déterminants pour
l'équilibre social de la nouvelle
résidence c'est cette concertation qui
existe aujourd'hui de manière
facultative vous l'avez dit au niveau
règlementaire sera ainsi remonté au
niveau législatif pour lui conférer un
caractère obligatoire d'autre part le
gouvernement propose de motiver et
notifier la décision de non attribution
réservataire qui pourra s'il le souhaite
en cas de désaccord saisir la commission
de coordination prévue par la loi qui
doit permettre de régler le différent à
l'amiable la proposition de loi prévoit
par ailleurs une délégation automatique
du contingent préfectoral au maire or
par dévolue aux fonctionnaires de l'État
lors des mises en service de nouveaux
programmes de logements sociaux sur ce
point le gouvernement ne souhaite pas
que ce pouvoir de délégation de
l'essentiel du contingent préfectoral au
maire soit automatique aussi tout en
reconnaissant l'intérêt que peut
représenter cette mesure le gouvernement
a-t-il déposé un amendement pour faire
en sorte que cette délégation reste une
faculté à la main du préfet la
concertation préalable entre le maire le
bailleur social et les réservataires que
le gouvernement propose d'introduire
permettra au préfet d'apprécier
l'opportunité de déléguer tout ou partie
de son contingent au
maire comme madame la sénatrice estros
sassonne le le précise cette pratique
est déjà en vigueur dans certains
territoires aujourd'hui et cette mention
législative pourra en faciliter
l'extension à d'autres territoires
toutefois en l'absence d'un transfert de
responsabilité au maire en matière
d'accès au logement des plus défavorisés
responsabilité qui pèse uniquement sur
l'état comme je vous l'ai dit en
introduction et les bailleurs sociaux il
n'pparaît pas souhaitable de rendre
cette délégation automatique et de
maintenir la possibilité pour le préfet
d'en apprécier l'opportunité en fonction
du contexte local bien entendu dans
l'hypothèse d'une refonte plus global
des compétences et
responsabilités lié à une
décentralisation des politiques du
logement ce point pourra
évoluer enfin d'un point de vue plus
symbolique le Gouvernement partage la
préoccupation que la présidence des ol
puisse être exercé par les élus locaux
du territoire concernés toutefois les
agendas des élus ne permettent pas
toujours de se rendre dans les
commissions qui pour certaines ne
concernent que quelques logements et qui
chez beaucoup de bailleurs se réunissent
toutes les semaines ou toutes les deux
semaines et portent sur des logements
attribués répartis sur plusieurs
communes aussi le gouvernement propose
un amendement pour rendre plus
opérationnelle cette proposition
concernant la présidence des caléoles
qui permettra au maire de présider la
caléole pour les dossiers le concernants
toutefois le gouvernement est également
attentif au maintien de la présidence
intercommunale lorsque la Caléo est
intercommunale comme l'a d'ailleurs fait
la commission car l'échelon
intercommunale sera particulièrement
important dans les discussions à venir
concernant la décentralisation du
logement en conclusion le gouvernement
pourra donner un avis favorable à la
proposition de loi sous réserve des
petites modifications proposées en
particulier concernant la motivation des
éventuelle opposition à une attribution
ainsi que le caractère facultatif de la
délégation du contingent préfectoral
tout en permettant un dialogue local
renforcé en amont de la mise en service
des opérations de logements sociaux
surtout nous espérons pouvoir poursuivre
les travaux sur ce sujet dans le cadre
des travaux initiés sur la
décentralisation de la politique du
logement pour concrétiser les annonces
faites par le Président de la République
en recherchant à la fois le renforcement
du pouvoir local auquel nous croyons
l'attribution de responsabilité CLA que
nous voulons et la simplification des
processus auxquels nous sommes très
attachés pouvoir et responsabilité
doivent être indissociable sur un sujet
présentant un tel enjeu social pour nos
concitoyens au-delà de nos échanges
aujourd'hui je vous assure de la pleine
mobilisation la pleine écoute du
gouvernement et particulièrement de mon
collègue Patrice vergrit sur cet enjeu
majeur des politiques du logement social
en France je vous
remercie merci madame la ministre dans
la suite de la discussion générale la
parole est à notre collègue Pierre
meddeviel pour le groupe les
indépendants pour 5
minutes
monsieur le
Président Madame la Ministre madame la
rapporteur mes chers
collègues la politique du logement se
situe au carfour d'enjeux sociaux
environnementaux territoriaux et
économiqu il s'agit d'une politique
essentielle pour notre pays à forceorie
quand il est question de logement
social assurer à tous nos concitoyens un
logement décent adapter leurs moyens
financiers et à leurs besoins est un
enjeu essentiel nous en sommes tous
convaincus en ces mur à ce défi
s'engreffe d'autres non moins importants
comme par exemple améliorer les
performances énergétique de notre parc
immobilier rénover l'existant faciliter
l'accès à la propriété ou encore
garantir la mixité
sociale concernant ce dernier objectif
l'ampleur et l'état de l'offre de
logement social sont des marqueurs
importants les collectivités doivent
disposer d'un parc de logement social
salubre et suffisamment conséquent pour
accueillir dans de bonnes conditions les
populations à faibles ressources sans
pour autant les concentrer dans le même
espace il s'agit d'organiser de manière
équilibrée l'accueil des différentes
populations en fonction de leurs besoins
dans une perspective de solidarité
territoriale notre pays connaît une
crise du logement grave les élus locaux
en témoignent et nous interpellent à ce
sujet dans toutes nos
circonscription à ce défi d'ampleur il
faut apporter une réponse locale adap
à la diversité des territoires de leurs
habitants et de leurs besoins ce sont
les maires qui bénéficient d'une
connaissance fine de la réalité de
terrain il est essentiel de leur
permettre de reprendre la main sur la
politique du logement social sans pour
autant les exposer à des difficultés
nouvelles la montée en puissance récente
des intercommunalité sur les thématiques
du logement induit mécaniquement une
diminution du poids décisionnel des
mares en matière d'habitat pourtant ils
en sont les acteurs centraux et je le
répète connaissent parfaitement le pou
et les besoins de leur
communes aujourd'hui les maires ont peu
de poids au sein des commissions
d'attribution des logements sociaux ce
sont pourtant des décisions cruciales
dans la vie d'une commune le moindre
changement en matière d'organisation
spatiale de l'habitat de population
installée ou d'évolution de leur mode de
vie a un impact sur l'ensemble de
l'organisation de la
commune ce texte permet de revenir à une
prise de décision à l'échelon le plus
pertinent l'échelon communal en
renforçant la place et le pouvoir des
élus locaux c'est ce que nos maires
attendent ce sont d'ailleurs vers eux
que nos concitoyens se tourne en premier
lieu lorsqu'il est question de
comprendre les décisions d'attribution
de logements sociaux aujourd'hui le
Parlement avec cette proposition de loi
envoie un signal positif aux élus j'en
profite pour saluer et remercier son
auteur Sophie prima ainsi que la
rapporteur madame Dominique Estrosi
Sasson la politique du logement est un
enjeu majeur pour nos communes ce texte
va dans le bon sens et nous pouvons nous
en féliciter il s'agit d'une première
marche qui devra être suivie dans les
prochains mois d'une réflexion d'ampleur
sur la crise du logement que nous
traversons
nos concitoyens attendent une réponse à
la hauteur des difficultés qu'ils
éprouvent à se loger dans de bonnes
conditions il y a urgence à agir quant
au maire ils attendaient un signal fort
dans ce domaine ce texte devrait leur
donner une première satisfaction pour
ces différentes raisons notre groupe Les
Indépendants votera favorablement ce
texte il a déjà été largement consigné
par plusieurs de mes collègues je vous
remercie merci
la parole est à présent à notre collègue
Amel gaker pour le groupe Union
centriste pour 8
[Applaudissements]
minutes cher Dominique chers collègues
il est compliqué d'aborder le rôle des
maires dans l'attribution des logements
sociaux sans évoquer brièvement le
contexte du logement social dans notre
pays sa place particulière dans nos
communes nous assistons aujourd'hui à la
déflagration de la bombe sociale
annoncée de longue dates par les acteurs
du logement
198000 logements sociaux c'est la
production annuelle qui devrait être
celle de la France pour répondre à la
demande de nos concitoyens les plus
modestes pourtant ce sont environ 80000
logements sociaux qui seront construits
en 2023 des chiffres dramatiques
révélateurs d'une réalité alarmante
disant tout de la situation critique
dans laquelle nous sommes avec mon
groupe de l'Union centriste nous tenons
à saluer l'annonce par le ministre de la
création d'un fond dédié à la rénovation
des logements sociaux doté de 1,2
milliard d'euros pour les trois
prochaines années avec un objectif de
120000 rénovations par an cependant nous
serons attentifs quant au modalité de
financement du fond ainsi que sa mise en
œuvre concrète nous aurions aimé que
cette annonce s'accompagne de nouvelles
encourageantes du gouvernement pour la
construction de nouveaux logements
sociaux le logement social est le
baromètre de la capacité de notre pays à
loger les plus modestes à protéger les
plus fragiles à offrir un toit à des
familles entières ou revenus plafonnés
nous avons cessé de faire du logement
social dans notre pays une chance pour
nos concitoyens comme pour nos
collectivités nous en avons fait une
obligation et une contrainte pour de
nombreuses communes là où l'incitation
devrait être la règle la collaboration
entre État et collectivité devrait être
notre boussole dans l'optique de bâtir
une politique de logement pour les
Français qui peinent de plus en plus à
envisager l'avenir sinement et pourtant
les rles les mares pardon ont un rôle
central dans le développement du
logement social au travers de
l'attribution des permis de construire
de la garantie des emprunts par exemple
la proposition de loi dont il est
question aujourd'hui vise à corriger une
injustice ce rôle central ne l'aurait
pas reconnu concrètement à ce titre je
souhaite saluer le dépôt de cette
proposition de loi par notre collègue
Sophie prima avec ce texte nous faisons
nous nous faisons les porte-paroles des
élus locaux qui en ont assez d'être de
simples exécutants en matière de
logement social les élus locaux font
bien souvent le choix de construire des
logements sociaux sur leurs communes
contrairement à ce qui pourrait être dit
au détriment de logements intermédiaires
ou d'infrastructure et ce dans l'optique
de loger au milieux les plus modestes
pourtant ils n'ont pas pleinement la
main pour choisir les dossiers des
locataires en dépit des investissements
drastique fait par leur commune
aujourd'hui le maire ou son représentant
est seul au sein des commissions
d'attribution des logements sociaux au
côté de l'État ou des représentants des
organismes HLM seul parmi une dizaine de
membres voilà la réalité euh leur en
tout cas quotidien cette proposition de
loi visant à faire des élus locaux de
véritables décideurs en matière de
logements sociaux et donc une étape
majeure pour revaloriser le rôle des
élus et des collectivité dans
l'attribution de logements sociaux je
salue le travail de notre rapporteur
Dominique Estrosi Sasson son rapport met
en lumière les limites de la politique
actuelle d'attribution des logements et
le sentiment de dépossession des élus de
leur propres log ement sociaux un
constat que nous ne voulons plus
accepter les communes les élus locaux
cela a été dit je le redis doivent être
incontournable le travail réalisé en
commission des affaires économiques est
donc salutaire je salue la proposition
de donner au maire un droit de veto sur
les attributions je salue bien sûr
également la délégation systématique au
maire des droits de réservation de
logement de l'État lors de la première
attribution d'un programme neuf à ceux
qui igne l'usage abusif pardon de ce
droit de véau je réponds qu'il ne
connaissent ni le quotidien ni
l'engagement sincère des élus je préfère
faire confiance aux élus responsables et
qui ont à cœur de sauvegarder le bien
vivre ensemble dans leur commune ce
nouveau cadre qui fixe le droit de
véteau du maire et sa présidence dans
les commissions d'attribution des
logements au sein des office HLM
demeureront des signaux positifs pour
faciliter la construction de nouveaux
logements sociaux de répondre à une
demande de plus en plus conséquente je
le rappelle 2,4 millions de demandeurs
aujourd'hui cependant une série de
questions opérationnelles restent en
suspens nous avons eu l'occasion d'en d'
d'en échanger notamment l'organisation
des commissions au présidence tournante
lorsqu'il s'agit de commission
intercommunale de d'attribution de
logement la suite donnée aux demandes
lorsque le vetau est utiliser par
exemple ces difficultés opérationnelles
évoquées avec mes collègues du groupe de
l'Union centriste nouau vteront sans
hésitation ce texte car il initie un
signal fort en faveur du logement social
et de la nécessaire revalorisation de la
place des élus locaux dans ce domaine
certes ce texte ne réglera pas la grave
crise de logement que nous traversons
mais c'est un pas significatif vers ce
en quoi nous croyons ici dans cette
assemblée redonner aux élus le pouvoir
d'agir un premier pas qui demande à être
suivi d'un de vos engagements sur lequel
nous vous attendons fermement madame la
ministre vous et votre gouvernement la
fameuse grande loi de décentralisation
de la politique du logement je vous
remercie merci la parole est à notre
collègue Yannick jado pour 5
minutes monsieur le Président chers
collègues madame la présidente madame la
ministre euh l'abbé Pierre disait
gouverner c'est loger son peuple on se
souvient on va bientôt commémorer les 70
ans de l'hiver
54 et la question du logement social
reste une question criante la question
de l'accès au logement reste la première
préoccupation très souvent des
Françaises et des Français leur premier
poste de dépense et malheureusement la
situation reste
dramatique les chiffres on les
connaît plus de 4 millions de personnes
qui sont mal logés 2,4 millions de
familles qui attendent un logement
social 12 % de nos concitoyens qui
vivent en situation de précarité
énergétique et donc on a une part de
plus en plus importante de nos
concitoyens et nos concitoyennes qui
souffrent du mallogement qui ont des
difficultés d'accéder à la propriété ça
c'était le premier débat et qui
évidemment galère pour accéder au
logement social et pourtant malgré cet
enjeu majeur malgré ce défi malgré cette
préoccupation que nous entendons chacune
et chacun à chaque fois que nous
discutons avec nos
concitoyens le la politique du logement
est catastrophique depuis un certain
nombre d'années on l'a dit la chute de
la construction de logement neuf la
chute de la construction de logements
sociaux au fond une logique du logement
social qui est d'abord une logique de
prédation fiscale puisqu'il s'est agit
notamment de ponctionner plus de 10
milliards sur Action Logement et sur
l'ensemble des acteurs qui devraient
participer de l'accroissement du
logement social et signe dramatique au
moment où on devrait embaucher dans le
secteur du bâtiment c'est près de 100000
emplois qui sont
menacé et ça n'est certainement pas par
des lois antiquat qui font des personnes
qui ont du mal payer leur loyer que on
va évidemment régler les problèmes alors
j'ai bien compris madame la Présidente
tout ça c'est la faute de
l'écologie je pense qu'on va s'amuser je
pense qu'on va s'amuser dans les mois
qui viennent si à chaque fois que on
aborde un sujet un peu lourd la deè
phrase du discours c'est c'est la faute
de l'écologie punitive ça va être un peu
court mais il y a 70 ans il y a même pas
besoin d'écologie et pourtant il y avait
déjà il y avait déjà la
baperre donc comment traiter cette crise
évidemment il faut mobiliser l'ensemble
des acteurs du secteur et là
pardonnez-moi madame la ministre mais
c'est une catastrophe vous avez
intelligemment intelligemment fait
travailler l'ensemble des acteurs dans
le cadre du CNR
logement depuis la fondation abépierre
jusqu'à la Fédération française du
bâtiment ils ont travaillé pendant des
mois à construire des réponses pendant
des mois à essayer de trouver des
solutions opérationnelles pour les
collectivités comme pour l'État et pas
un de ces acteurs madame pas un depuis
la fondation bpierre jusqu'à la
Fédération française du bâtiment est
ressorti sans se sentir humilié de cette
cet exercice parce que vous avez méprisé
leurs conclusions et maintenant il va
falloir les remobiliser mais sur quelle
politique sur quel budget sur quel moyen
sur quel discours sur quelle
compétenence que sinon évidemment ça ne
marchera pas les moyens on les connaît
c'est aussi les moyens pour la
rénovation on a 6 millions de passoir
énergétique et on s'est aperçu qu'en
plus de la précarité l'hiver c'est éit
devenu une précarité dramatique l'été 70
% des logements dans les quartiers
prioritaires de la ville souffre
d'étouffement donc on est sur ce sujetl
il va falloir
avancer alors oui il va falloir aussi
respecter les règles j'ai entendu
beaucoup citer la loi
etue mais qu'attendez-vous madame la
ministre le gouvernement pour exiger des
préfets qu'ils imposent la loi su qu'
impose sur les
départements moi je veux bien que ce
soit madame la Présidente dans les Alpes
Maritimes la quasitalité des communes
sont hors des clous de la loi SRU alors
oui il va falloir l'appliquer si nous
voulons du logement social dans notre
pays
enfin sur la proposition sur la
proposition oui nous défendons que la
collégialité est le moyen de rés
oui nous défendons que l'objectivité des
critères c'est le moyen de répondre à la
discrimination donc nous nous y
opposerons
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Fabien Guay pour le groupe CRCE kanaki
pour 5
minutes ma prière intervention
toujours président
félicitation bon
allez allez
allez monsieur le Président Madame la
ministre mes chers collègues ce projet
de loi a été annoncé comme poursuivant
l'objectif de renforcer les pouvoirs du
maire en terme d'attribution de
logements sociaux cette thématique est
en effet au cœur de leur préoccupation
car 80 % des audience sollicité en
mairie porte sur la question du logement
pourtant nous pensons que cette
proposition de loi ne répond pas en tout
cas pas seul au principal problème
c'est-à-dire la pénurie du logement
alors que cette tendance s'amplifie en
France touchant en premier lieu les
ménages les plus précaires on dénombre
actuellement 2,4 millions de demandeurs
en attente d'un logement social chaque
année ce sont 20 % des demandes de
logement sociaux qui sont satisfaites en
France et seulement 10 % en
Île-de-France en zone tendu il faut en
outre constater une véritable hausse de
la file d'attente chaque année le délai
moyen pour obtenir un logement étant
actuellement de 3 ans minimum en
Île-de-France en effet la popérisation
de la société française conduit au fait
que les personnes occupant un logement
social le quitte moins qu'avant de même
l'accession à la propriété s'est
complexifié pour non nombre de personnes
et le parcours résidentiel est devenu un
parcours du combattant puisqueune
majeure partie de la population avec les
petits salaires les taux d'intérêt
bancaire élevés et privé d'accession à
la propriété surtout on ne construit
plus assez de logements sociaux alors
que le nombre de demandeurs augmente
chaque année alors que l'on comptait
pour l'année 2017 environ 105000
logements mis en chantier pour l'année
2022 on n rens que 85000 alors que le le
besoin serait à hauteur de 200000 soit
au moins deux fois plus que ces
prévisions cela tient notamment au fait
que les moyens à loués sont insuffisants
comme ceux des bailleurs affaiblis par
la réduction de loyer de solidarité qui
n'est plus compensé par l'État voici
madame la ministre le résultat de votre
politique en 6 ans 10 milliards d'euros
ponctionnés au bailleur et donc moins de
rénovation et moins de construction
c'est pourquoi nous considérons que
cette loi frappe à côté du principal
problème les maires ne sont pas mis en
difficulté pour répondre aux besoins de
du de logement social parce qu'ils ne
disposeraient pas de pouvoirs suffisants
lors des commissions d'attribution mais
parce qu'ils doivent composer avec cette
pénurie en ce sens la présente loi
n'aura aucun effet sur les difficultés
de fond et créera l'illusion d'un
pouvoir renforcé du maire qui reste en
réalité tributaire d'un nombre
insuffisant de places à allouer en parc
social il y a 10 ans on attribué 500000
logements socials par an en France
aujourd'hui c'est 400000 les maires ne
veulent pas gérer la pénurie mais
répondre aux besoins de leur population
plus encore nous nous opposons au droit
de vé qui a été introduit introduit en
commission cela aurait non seulement
pour effet de casser des parcours
d'accès au logement de certains ménages
mais cela rendrait également les maires
responsables de l'échec de la politique
du logement mené depuis nombreuses
années par par votre gouvernement madame
la ministre car nous considérons que
tout le monde devrait pouvoir accéder à
un habitat digne qu'il soit public ou
privé si nous sommes favorables au fait
de confier davantage de pouvoir au maire
nous considérons que cela doit se faire
en conservant une collégialité qui
permet notamment de se prémunir de
dérives même si ces comportements sont
marginaux chez nos élus nous proposons
donc en premier de généraliser
l'obligation d'anonymiser les demandes
de de logements sociaux enfin la
commission des affaires économiques a
décidé de confier au maire l'intégralité
des attributions pour les logements
sociaux neuf en agissant ainsi vous
excluez de fait toutes les personnes
reconnues prioritaires au titre du dallo
les personnes en situation de handicap
les familles entassées dans un logement
les femmes victimes de violence ou
encore les enfants souhaitant la la
décohabitation pour nous ceci n'est pas
acceptable cette proposition de loi
constitue donc un cadeau empoisonné fait
au maire un transfert de compétenenceces
qui ne s'accompagne d'aucun transfert de
ressources budgétaires et qui n'apporte
aucune solution au fond du problème
l'État est ainsi en passe de se défaire
de la politique du logement souscouvert
d'honorer les maires et de leur marquer
sa confiance le tout ayant été annoncé
rappelons-le dans un contexte médiatique
très chargé autour du logement social
suite aux révoltes lié à la mort du
jeune naë nous proposons donc Madame la
Ministre plutôt que de s'entenir à cette
loi que vous agissiez pour réunir
d'urgence le commité interministériel
des villes pour répondre à l'urgence
sociale dans toutes ces dimensions pour
toutes ces raisons notre groupe CRCE
kanaki s'opposera à cette proposition de
loi je vous
remercie merci la parole est désormais à
notre collègue hen Cabanel pour le
groupe RDSE pour 5
minutes monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre madame la rapporteur madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
économiques mes chers collègues M et
logement cet après-midi le temp est
donné au Sénat sur deux priorités qui
nous animent dans cette émicycle c'est
un signe fort donné aux élus de nos
collectivités locales qui vivent un
malaise sans précédent après un débat
sur l'accession à la propriété et avant
l'examen de la ppel renforçant la
sécurité des élus locaux nous examinons
la proposition de loi de notre collègue
Sophie prima ce texte résume les
contours du mandat du maire son utilité
sa responsabilité son éthique il marque
le top départ d'une réflexion qui doit
être globale sur le logement avec la
nécessité urgente ça a été dit plusieurs
fois d'un texte général qui recouvre
tous les enjeux dans ce contexte de
crise à répétition nous ne pouvons plus
gérer les problématiques en découpant
les politiques publiques en silo car
elles sont
interconnectées derrière ce texte il y a
un sujet en filigramme de nos débat la
nécessité d'une mixité sociale c'est
tout l'enjeu de notre politique de
logement qui débouchera Infiné sur des
enjeux plus larges comme la politique
urbaine et
sociale le président de la République
avait annoncé au 220 maires qu'il
recevait le 4 juillet dernier à
l'élyisée sa volonté de je cite remettre
dans leur mains l'attribution des
logements sociaux le chantier était
censé avancer d'ici la fin de l'été avec
pour objectif d'éviter une France de
société visant je cite aussi dot d's
vivant pardon do d's mes points de texte
gouvernemental à l'horizon cette PPL
déposée en avril n'est pas un texte de
réponse à des émeutes mais à une
proposition de renforcement du rôle du
maire dans l'attribution des logements
sociaux le contexte il est vrai semble
déséquilibré le maire disposant d'un
rôle central tant politique que
juridique pour le développement de
logement sociaux sur son territoire ne
retrouve pas cette importance au sein de
la commission d'attribution des
logements de et de l'examen de
l'occupation de logement caléol en effet
il est garant du respect de la loi SRU
avec la responsabilité d'accorder les
permis de construire et d'exercer le
droit de préemption favorisant
l'émergence de projets garantissant
l'accès à un logement abordable pour
tous et la mixité sociale mais il est
isolé et ne dispose que de peu de poids
au sein de la Caléo cette PPL a donc
pour objectif de R donner du poids dans
la décision du maire à noter il détient
déjà parmi les six membres de la
commission une voix prépondérante en cas
d'égalité des voix cette PPL proposa
initialement deux évolutions que le
maire devienne président de la Caléo que
cinq membres de son conseil municipal le
rejoignne afin de venir équilibrer le
nombre global des membres en commission
un amendement est venu compléter le
dispositif en en octroyant un droit de
vetto et c'est là en ce qui me concerne
que le bablesse car ce droit de véteau
ne renforcera pas son pouvoir
d'attribution mais son droit de refus et
l'URA un seul décisionnaire au sein de
la Commission dans un monde parfait le
mot clientélisme n'existerait pas mais
vous le savez ce monde parfait n'existe
pas et depuis des années certains maires
se servent du levier locatif comme d'un
instrument de clientélisme et de
maintien de l'entre soi n'oublions pas
que l'héritage des inégalités sociales
entre communes a été conduit sous la
responsabilité de ceux qui préfèrent par
par exemple payer des pénalités plutôt
que de construire des logements sociaux
les chiffres sont éclairants 1100
communes ne respectent pas leur
obligation en matière de logement social
sur les 2091 communes de plus de 3500
habitants situés sur le territoire s SRU
si elles sont certes à majorité engagé
sous l'effet de la loi SRU dans un
rattrapage de leur retard 631 d'entre
elles sont soumises à prélèvement pour
un montant global de 85,4 millions
d'euros qui à financer le logement
locatif social c'est pourquoi si ce
texte a le mérite d'ouvrir le débat plus
large du logement mon groupe est assez
mitigé au-delà de ce risque généré par
le droit de véau on imagine mal une
équipe municipale de six personnes venir
en Caléo compte tenu des des agendas
chronophage l'organisation à mettre en
place semble complexe et le quorum sera
quelquefois difficilement atteint c'est
pourquoi nous proposons une limitation
du nombre qui pourrait être de trois
membres du conseil municipal
pour conclure je pense que pour garder
une impartialité et une éthique dans le
choix des locataires il ne faut surtout
pas de droit de véto mais il faut que
les arguments du maire et de son équipe
soient entendus et respectés pour que
demain le maire et son équipe soient
motivés pour la construction de
l'ogement sociaux c'est un contrat
gagnant gagnant qu'il faut inventer
logement va être l'une des crises
majeures que nous allons traverser dans
les prochains mois avec l'inflation avec
la hausse des prix de l'énergie avec la
précarité grandissante mais aussi avec
l'augmentation de prix de l'immobilier
qui s'est multiplié par 3 depuis l'an
2000 c'est le poste de dépense des
foyers le plus tendu la prochaine étape
et nous l'espérons tous urgemment sera
un texte d'ampleur sur le logement et
j'espère sans tabou je vous
remercie merci la parole est à notre
collègue Bernard Bui pour le groupe RDP
pour 7
minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
madame la présidente de la commission
des affaires économiques également
rapporteur mes chers collègues la
proposition de loi que nous examinons
vise à renforcer le rôle des maires dans
l'attribution des logements sociaux ce
texte constitue le premier que le Sénat
examine en séance pour cette nouvelle
session ordinaire démontrant ainsi
l'importance fondamentale du logement et
plus particulière du logement social je
salue le travail de notre collègue
Sophie prima et de notre rapporteur et
nouvelle présidente de la commission des
affaires économiques Dominique Estrosi
Sasson donc nous dont nous connaissons
tous l'expertise et l'engagement sur ce
sujet cependant le travail mené en
commission sur cette proposition de loi
a radicalement transformé le dispositif
prévu par ce texte en adoptant
l'amendement de réécriture de l'article
unique de la rapporteur en commission
le droit de vetau du maire s'est
substitué à la volonté de mieux
représenter la commune autrement dit
nous sommes passés d'une logique de
renforcement de la représentation de la
commune au sein des commissions
d'attribution des logements et d'examen
de l'occupation des logement à une
logique de vetau du maire sur
l'attribution d'un logement par ailleurs
cet amendement a confié la présidence de
cette commission d'attribution au maire
de la commune ou à son représentant sauf
lorsque le P c est à l'origine de sa
constitution auquel cas c'est le
président de leepci ou son représentant
qui exercera la présidence de plus cet
amendement a également supprimé la voie
prépondérante du maire en cas d'égalité
des voix enfin il a introduit la
systématisation de la délégation des
droits de réservation de l'État au maire
lors de la première location d'un
programme u bien entendu notre groupe
adhère à l'esprit initial du texte et au
renforce effectif du rôle des maires
dans l'attribution des logements sociaux
confier la présidence de la commission
d'attribution des logements et d'examen
de l'occupation des logements au maire
est une bonne chose selon nous tout
comme l'étit le renforcement du
contingent communal et comme l' la
délégation des droits de réservation de
l'État au maire nous comprenons la
problématique des quum pour cette
solution néanmoins la logique du véau
nous pose un problème en effet donner le
pouvoir au maire de refuser des
locataire semble être à nos yeux un
renforcement du pouvoir d'exclusion du
logement social et non d'attribution
pour parler simplement c'est un
renforcement du pouvoir de non
attribution des maires par conséquent je
rappelle que nous adhérons à la visée
initiale de cette proposition de loi
mais la méthode retenue s'en éloigne un
peu le groupe RDPI privilégie un
renforcement du contingent communal en
intégrant deux représentants
supplémentaires de la commune dont un
issu de l'opposition avec le maire leur
voix compterait double ce qui porterait
à six voix le poids du bloc communal
soit autant que celui des organismes
d'habitation à loyer modéré or nous
souhaitons conserver au Mair une voie
prépondérante en cas d'égalité puisque
dans cette nouvelle structure ce cas de
figure se présenterait plus souvent nous
partageons également la nécessité de
confier au maire la présidence de la
commission d'attribution des logements
et d'examen de l'occupation des
logements si nous comprenons les
difficultés de quorum nous considérons
toutefois que notre position est
équilibrée et permet donc de contner
cette difficulté sur un autre sujet
notre groupe propose également
d'intégrer au sein de la commission
d'attribution des logements et d'examen
l'occupation des logements un
représentant du conseil départemental
avec voix consultative mes chers
collègues vous le savez tous dans le
monde du logement social le département
est tout sauf un inconnu si les
situations varient d'un département à
l'autre je peux citer l'exemple du fond
unique logement et habitat dans la Drome
qui permet au public fragilisé d'obtenir
une aide financière pour couvrir les
accès au logebain comme la garantie de
loyer par celui qui rentre dans le
logement social dans la construction
aussi les départements jouent un rôle
important je pense notamment à la
délégation des aides à la pierre pour ce
qui est du parc locatif social et du
parc privé ces aides permettent de finan
c'est la construction l'acquisition la
réhabilitation de logements locatifs
sociaux ou encore l'amélioration de
l'habitat privé qu'il soit question des
bailleurs des propriétaires ou des
occupants enfin reconnaissons que le
département acteur essentiel de la
solidarité dispose d'une connaissance
solide et complémentaire de celle des
maires sur les proposisations
fragilisées et leurs problématiqu
spécifiques aujourd'hui il nous apparaît
donc opportun de leur permettre de
partager le leur expertise sur ce sujet
au sein des commissions d'attribution
des logements et d'examen de
l'occupation des logements plus
largement mes chers collègues le
ministre chargé du Logement a annoncé
travailler sur une loi de
décentralisation de la politique du
logement nous considérons qu'une
logement ne peut se faire sans vérifier
au préalable que les compétences qui se
verrai décentralisés aux élus locaux
soit bien des compétences qu'ils ont
déjà la capacité d'assurer que que ce
soit en terme de moyens financiers bien
évidemment mais également en terme
d'ingénierie sur ce dernier point force
de constater que si l'Agence nationale
de la cohésion des territoires n'est pas
encore assez connu et sollicité par les
mares lorsqu'elle l'est les résultats
sont souvent bien satisfaisant bien sûr
ce n'est pas parfait et nous avons tous
des témoignages de difficultés mais il
semble que la dynamique positive avec
une meilleure connaissance et
reconnaissance de l'agence elle pourra
mieux adapter ses méthodes de travail
aux réalités concrètes de ce qu'en
attendent les élus cela va dans les deux
sens nous serons donc particulièrement
attentifs sur un point pour chaque
compétence déléguée un travail préalable
devra être réalisé afin de vérifier que
cette compétence soit bien applicable et
mobilisable par les élus locaux face à
la crise du logement et au
rangérissement du prix de l'argent nous
ne pouvons pas nous permettre plusieurs
années d'adaptation mes chers collègues
sur un sujet comme celui-ci
nous sommes beaucoup plus d'accord pour
travailler sur l'essentiel mais pas sur
le chemin choisi notre groupe reste donc
ouvert au compromis dans l'intérêt des
Français et se prononcera sur le texte
en fonction des débats et de l'examen
des amendements je vous
remerci merci la parole est à présent
notre collègue Vivian Artigalas pour le
groupe socialiste écologiste républicain
pour 5
[Applaudissements]
minutes
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre madame la rapporteur et
président de la commission des affaires
économiques mes chers collègues ce texte
même s'il a été enregistré au Sénat en
avril dernier s'inscrit finalement dans
la ligée du discours du président de la
République qui après les émeutes avait
annoncé plus de décentralisation plus de
simplification et de redonner du pouvoir
aux élus locaux dans les attribution de
logements sociaux Emmanuel Macron avait
promis des réponses nous les attendons
toujours comme nous attendons toujours
le pacte de confiance entre l'État et
l'ushh ayant vu son article unique
réécrit en commission cette PPL
introduit finalement un droit de veto
motivé du maire dans les commissions
d'attribution de logement conserve le
principe d'une présidente de cette même
commission par le maire et permet aussi
que cette fonction puisse être déléguée
au président d'un EPCI enfin le texte de
la Commission propose que les
conventions de réservation prévoient
systématiquement la délégation des
droits de réservation de l'État au maire
lors de la première location d'un
programme neuf en premier lieu le droit
de vetto accordé au maire introduit un
risque de pouvoir arbitraire qui
pourrait faire reculer les politiques de
développement de la mixité sociale mise
en œuvre ces 10 dernières années il
risque aussi de menacer l'indépendance
des organismes HLM qui collaborent
certes avec les élus et l'État mais
doivent répondre en toute impartialité
aux problématiques suivantes mettre en
œuvre la politique du logement d'abord
et du logement des personnes
prioritaires procéder au relogement
rendu nécessaire par les programmes de
rénovation urbaine assurer les objectifs
de mixité sociale par ailleurs il existe
déjà des outils ils sont certes
perfectibles mais ils gagneraiit à être
développés et améliorés en effet ils
permettent aux maires de mieux orienter
les attributions de logements sociaux
sur leur territoire les collectivités
peuvent ainsi mettre en place des plans
partenariaux de gestion de la demande et
d'information des demandeurs définir des
priorités formalisé dans la cotation de
la demande éclairer les commissions
d'attribution sur l'équilibre desés
idence et définir un cadre commun
d'orientation des attributions au
travers des conventions intercommunales
d'attribution alors que les règles
actuelles protègent les élus locaux des
recours contre une décision de refus
d'attribution puisque les plaintes sont
intentées contre les organismes HLM et
jamais contre la collectivité locale
membre de la commission d'attribution le
rôle central de cette PPL souhaite
accorder au maire risque qui souhaite
accorder au maire risque au contraire de
les exposer à ce type de poursuite pour
rendre au Mair leur pouvoir d'agir il
nous semble qu'il faudrait surtout
chercher à développer la concertation et
la coopération entre l'État et les élus
c'était d'ailleurs l'une des
propositions formulé le 6 juillet
dernier par le groupe de travail
décentralisation du Sénat piloté par le
président Larcher conclure des pactes
territoriaux entre l'État et les EPCI à
fiscalité propre ou des conventions terr
iale de coopération entre l'État et les
bailleurs sociaux ensuite ensuite annexé
au programme local de l'habitat dernière
critique et non des moindres puisquelle
concerne le calendrier et le cadre
législatif cette PPL risque fort d'être
incompatible avec la généralisation de
la gestion en flux des réservations de
logements sociaux avec laquelle la
désignation des candidats sera décidée
soit par le réservataire soit par le
bailleur y rajouter un troisè
intervenant à la personne du maire
paraît être une complexification
contraire à l'objectif de simplification
ambitionné par ce texte face au problème
de logement la réponse n'est pas tant à
trouver dans les conditions
d'attribution que la dans la nécessaire
hausse de la production de logement or
madame la ministre c'était sur ce point
que les bailleurs sociaux en particulier
vous attendaient et en dépit de quelques
annonces positives que vous avez formulé
jeudi dernier au congrès de l'ushh cette
demande demeure lettre morte encore pour
cette année et aucune perspective de
long terme n'a été engagée l'annulation
du comité interministériel des villes
encore une fois qui devait se tenir le 9
octobre et la tenue d'un conseil
national de la refondation à la dernière
minute jeudi dernier qui n'a débouché
sur aucune annonce du gouvernement ont
accru l'exaspération des élus des
quartiers populaires même si nous
partageons les constat de ce texte et
reconnaissons que la question du
peuplement est centrale cette PPL ne
résoudra pas les véritables problèmes le
manque d'accompagnement social du
logement d'abord la baisse de la
construction et une offre de logements
sociaux insuffisantes la belle affaire
d'avoir un plus grand pouvoir
d'attribution si les logements ne sont
pas là ce que nous racclamons
insassablement sur ces bancs c'est un
véritable travail global engagé sur la
question du logement l'urgence c'est
également de rendre au aux organismes
HLM leurs ressources pour relancer la
production de logements sociaux le
groupe socialiste ne votera pas cette
proposition de
loi merci la parole est à présent à
notre collègue Laurence Garnier pour le
groupe les républicains pour 5
[Applaudissements]
minutes monsieur monieur le président
madame la ministre madame la rapporteur
chers collègues sous des apparences
assez technique cette proposition de loi
pour renforcer le rôle des maires dans
l'attribution des logements sociaux est
un véritable levier pour répondre au
sentiments d'impuissance des maires pour
redonner de la clarté au processus
d'attribution des logements qui est mal
compris par nos concitoyens et pour
mieux prendre en compte les besoins des
habitants de ces logements les maires
sont les premiers acteurs de la
construction de logements sociaux au
sein de leurs communes ce sont eux qui
accordent les permis de construire et
ils sont pour beaucoup de communes
françaises concernés par la loi SRU qui
leur impose des quotas de logements
sociaux malgré ces missions essentielles
leur rôle dans l'attribution des
logements est
aujourd'huireint et nous constatons tous
les jours les conséquences de ces
difficultés d'abord en terme
d'efficacité les maires sont ceux qui
connaissent le mieux leur commune ils
sont donc les plus qualifiés pour
garantir l'équilibre des attributions en
faveur des nouveaux habitants qui
intégreront les logements
sociaux leur unique objectif est de
permettre à chacun une arrivée réussie
au sein de leur commune en Loire
Atlantique le maire de
commune littorale de 2000
habitants me parlait l'autre jour d'un
habitant imposé par le bailleur social
au sein de la commission d'attribution
des logements sociaux lui le maire de
Mesquer avait
défendu le dossier d'un homme qui
dormait depuis plusieurs semaines dans
sa voiture sur sa commune le dossier de
cet homme a été
refusé et l'homme en question est décéd
15 jours
après cela nous permet de mesurer à quel
point les maires doivent être remis au
cœur de ce processus et à quel point
c'est aussi leur légitimité et leur
crédibilité vis-à-vis des habitants qui
est en
jeu nos habitants ne connaissent pas le
fonctionnement de ces commissions
d'attribution des logements il pens et
c'est bien normal que c'est le maire qui
et ils en veulent au maire lorsqu'un
habitant qu'ils connaissent et qui est
en difficulté n'obtient pas de place
dans un logement social ces situations
génèent de l'incompréhension et de la
colère une élue du vignoble Nanta me
parlait l'autre jour des reproches que
lui avait fait sa population suite à un
dossier rejeté en
commission cette fois-ci c'était des
reproches parfois ce sont des agressions
verbales parfois ce sont des agressions
physiques nous ne le savons que trop
bien alors bien sûr rien ne doit jamais
excuser ces attitudes de
certains mais redonner sa place au maère
c'est aussi crédibiliser son action
vis-à-vis de nos concitoyens en confiant
la présidence de ces commissions
d'attribution au maire en renforçant la
place et le nombre des élus locaux
présents et en accordant au maire un
droit de veto cette proposition de loi
répond à ces enjeux je tiens à préciser
également qu'il ne s'agit pas au travers
de ce droit de veto qui devra être
argumenté et justifié de trier les bons
ou les mauvais habitants mais de mettre
à profit la connaissance que le maire a
de sa commune pour savoir quel profil
d'habitant ils pourront accompagner
quels habitants pourront trouver chez
eux un équilibre de vie en fonction de
la typologie de la commune derrière ces
évolutions techniques ce texte va donc
permettre d'améliorer le fonctionnement
de notre démocratie d'augmenter la
capacité d'action des communes et de
mieux intégrer les habitants des
logements sociaux à la vie de ces
communes je voudrais saluer pour
terminer l'auteur de cette proposition
de loi notre collègue Sophie prima qui a
traduit dans ce texte législatif
beaucoup d'attentes et d'intentions
exprimé et partagé
par les élus en particulier suite aux
émeutes que notre pays a connu en
juillet dernier je remercie également la
rapporteur du texte la présidente
Dominique Estrosi Sasson pour le travail
réalisé pour affiner encore ce texte que
le groupe des Républicains votera avec
enthousiasme merci de votre
attention merci la parole est à présent
à Monsieur Josua auchochard pour les
sénateurs ne figurant sur la liste
d'aucun groupe pour 3
minutes merci monsieur le Président
Madame la la ministre madame le
rapporteur chers collègues 11 millions
en effet ce sont près de 11 millions de
personnes qui vivent en habitat à loyer
modéré dans les quelques 5 millions de
logements que le territoire français
avec près d'un Français sur deux qui a
vécu ou VI en HLM d'après l'Union
sociale pour l'habitat les HLM
bénéficient pourtant d'une image souvent
négative entaché par des problématiques
de violence d'insécurité de tapage ou
d'insalubrité si les offices publics àlm
remplissent souvent leur mission de
gestion ils doivent faire face de façon
de plus en plus forte à des locataires
posant problème violence trafic en tout
genre cambrouillolage destruction des
biens public incendie de véhicules
poubelles menace intimidation nuisance
nocturne tous ces faits détérieur le
quotidien VI des habitants qui
n'aspirent qu'à une chose vivre
tranquillement localement le maire est
très souvent l'élu le plus accessible
l'autorité la plus proche il est
directement responsable vis-à-vis des
habitants de sa commune mais il est
aussi le garant de la tranquillité
publique au travers de son pouvoir de
police les élus de la commune sont les
plus informés de la situation locale et
les plus à même de juger opportun ou non
l'installation de nouveaux habitants
dans des logements à loyers modérés les
critères d'éligibilité pour bénéficiers
un logement social sont nombreux et
c'est à la commission d'attribution des
logements que revient la tâche de
proposer un logement adapté au
demandeurs
demandeurs d'ailleurs toujours plus
nombreux atteignant quasiment 2 million
et demi de dossiers en attente soit une
progression de plus de 7
%. actuellement la commune représentée
par son maire est sousreésenté en la
commission d'attribution des logements
de ce fait le maire peut se voir
attribuer des habitants qui poseraient
ou aurait poser des problèmes de
tranquillité publique ou de salubrité
publique rendre un peu de pouvoir aux
élus locaux et tout l'enjeu de ce texte
et plus largement tout l'enjeu des
textes que nous aurons étudiés à
proposer pour les années à venir ce
texte n'est pas en soi une finalité ça a
été rappelé mais mais il pose les bases
d'un contrat républicain plus
respectueux des élus municipaux les
défis de demain en matière de logements
sociaux sont grands comme celui
d'intégrer les places de prison dans la
prise en compte des minimas définis par
la loi SRU afin d'en finir avec la
double peine des communes ou encore
permettre l'expulsion de logement social
des délinquants condamnés dans des
conditions plus larges que celles qui
sont prévu aujourd'hui dans toutes ces
réformes vous trouverez les sénateurs du
rassemblement national et je l'espère
sur d'autes formations politiques en
première
ligne merci la parole est à présent à BO
pour le groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicain pour 4
[Applaudissements]
minutes monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre madame la rapporteur chers
collègues 2,42 millions de ménages éta
de logement social à la fin de l'année
dernière madame la ministre à l'opposé
de cette réalité vous avez indiqué que
le nombre d'agréments de logements
sociaux se situé auutour de 85000 en fin
2023 comme vous l'avez vous-même reconnu
ce chiffre est dement insuffisant déjà
lors des deux exercices précédents nous
étions moins de 100000 logements par an
alors que l'objectif je vous le rappelle
était fixé à 250000 sur 2 ans comme quoi
il n'existe pas non plus de pensé
magique il ne suffit pas de décréter l'
objectif pour que celui-ci se
réalise lors du dernier projet de loi de
finances j'interprétaé votre
prédécesseur afin de mettre à œuvre un
véritable P Marchal du logement
aujourd'hui malgré nos alertes répétées
aucune mesure d'ampleur n'a été prise la
situation est de plus en plus
alarmante c'est donc avec une grande
inquiétude et de manière de plus en plus
urgente que nous réitérons notre appel
auprès de vous aussi chers collègues
j'ai bien peur qu'à travers cette prop
de loi nous prenions le problème à
l'envers nous sommes aujourd'hui face à
une grave pénurie de logements sociaux
c'est cette pénurie et la tension
qu'elle génère dans le parc social qui
contribue à la perte d'influence des
manè dans l'attribution de logement le
cœur du problème ce ne sont pas les
modalités d'attribution de logement
sociaux mais bel et bien leur
production le cœur du problème c'est la
capacité d'investir des mailleurs
sociaux le cœur du problème c'est la RLS
le cœur du problème c'est les 15
milliards d'Uros d'économies sur les
politiques du logement au cours de ces 5
dernières années ceci étant dit nous ne
sommes pas opposés à une meilleure
écoute de la vie des maires dans
l'attribution de logements sociaux et
une prise en compte de leur connaissance
F de leur territoire et de leur
population ceci serait d'autant plus
utile que la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation et l'accroissement des des
contraintes urbanistiques participe déjà
à désinciter certains maires à s'engager
dans la construction de logements
sociaux pour autant les principales
dispositions qui sont présentées dans
cette proposition de loi ne nous
semblent ni réalistes dans leur mise en
œuvre sur le terrain ni souhaitable sur
le fond tout d'abord confier la
présidence des C au maire posera
forcément des problèmes d'organisation
nous savons que le patrimoine des
bailleurs sociaux ne s'arrête pas la
frontière d'une seule commune
concrètement comment organiser les C sur
le terrain en changeant de présidence à
chaque dossier encore une fois devons
veiller à ce à ce que notre volonté de
légiférer ne complexifie pas
l'organisation au quotidien sur nos
territoires comme c'est parfois
malheureusement le cas d'autre part
notre politique deement social doit se
trouver en équilibre entre l'écoute des
des élus locaux qui qui également le
respect des objectifs de l'État
notamment en matière de mixité sociale
et de logement dans les personnes
prioritaires les maires sont déjà
écoutés et soutenus mieux écouter les
les élus locaux dans les décisions
d'attribution de logement neous doit pas
nous emener à renverser totalement le
balcier dans le sens inverse or offrir
purement et simplement un droit de
véteau au mer viendrait totalement
rompre cet équilibre une telle
disposition menacerait la cohérence
globale de notre action en matière de
logement social et cela poserait
également la question de l'exposition
juridique des Maes dans le cadre du
recours à
nonattribution enfin la proposition de
généraliser la délégation des droits de
réservation de l'État à la commune lors
de la premiè première mise en location
d'un programme neuf semble elle beaucoup
plus mieuxéquilibré elle permet de
renforcer l'écoute des maires sans
rompre le nécessaire équilibre du
système comme l'a dit notre rapporteur
cette pratique est déjà très répendu et
les choix de fonctionnent très bien sans
que le législateur ait besoin
d'intervenir le président du Sénat il y
a quelques jours maintenant nous
demander de moins légiférer pour mieux
légiférer or cette proposition de loi ne
servira pas de régler les difficultés
des mal logés et elle est
malheureusement sur le terrain
inapplicable nous oposerons donc à cette
proposition de loi telle que nous ai
présenté je vous remercie
merci la parole est désormais à notre
collègue jeanrmond Hugonet pour le
groupe les républicains pour 4
[Applaudissements]
minutes
monsieur le président madame la
présidente madame la ministre étant
donné la crise immobilière brutale qui
déstabilise le secteur de la
construction et de la location le
logement est clairement l'un des thèmes
politiques les plus scruté du
moment ce n'est donc pas un hasard si le
premier texte sur lequel nous avons à
débattre est celui porté par notre
collèg Sophie prima sur le renforcement
du rôle des maires dans l'attribution
des logements dissociaux il s'agit tout
simplement de donner enfin au maire un
poids cohérent avec les responsabilités
politiques et juridiques qui sont les
leurs pour assurer le logement de leur
population ici au Sénat nous sommes
convaincus depuis longtemps de cette
absolue nécessité en juillet dernier le
président Gérard Larcher déplorant la
marginalisation des maires dans
l'attribution des logements a lui-même
rappelé que le logement devait être la
première des politiques à rendre au
maire il semble que depuis le président
de la République l'a entendu puisqu'il a
indiqué dernièrement son intention de
travailler sur les attributions de
logements sociaux afin de laisser une
plus grande marge de manœuvre au maires
et leur donner une meilleure maîtrise du
peuplement de leur commune en effet la
place des maires dans les commissions
d'attribution des logement et d'examen
de l'occupation des logements la caléole
n'est pas à la mesure de leur rôle
centrale dans le développement du
logement disocial notamment à travers
l'attribution des permis de construire
et de la garantie
d'emprunt de fait l'attribution des
logements leur échappe majoritairement
il pèse peu dans les commissions
d'attribution à côté de l'État et des
organismes HLM étant seul parmi une
dizaine de membres à défaut donc
d'établir l'égalité numérique entre la
délégation du bailleur social et celle
de la commune la commission des affaires
économiques a adopté un amendement du
rapporteur donnant au maire un droit de
véau plutôt qu'une voix prépondérante en
cas de partage ce véteau devrait être
motivé et pourrait par exemple s'appuyer
sur la qualification du parc social et
de son occupation établie par le
bailleur et d'ors et déjà prévu par les
textes par ailleurs la Commission des
affaires économiques estime Essen
d'attribuer au maire la présidence de
ces commissions tout en veillant bien
sûr à conserver leur caractère
intercommunal lorsque c'est le cadre de
fonctionnement
établi enfin la Commission propose de
généraliser la délégation des droits de
réservation de l'État au maire lors de
la première mise en location d'un
programme neuf comme le rend déjà
possible une lecture souple du décret de
2020 qui régit la mise en œuvre de la
cotation de la gestion en flux et des
conventions de réservation
il s'agit donc bien de redonner une
vraie capacité au maire pour maîtriser
le peuplement d'une résidence en lui
donnant la possibilité d'attribuer
environ la moitié des nouveaux logements
cela paraît également de nature à
soutenir la construction de nouve de
nouveaux logements sociaux et
l'application de la loi su en permettant
de répondre à la demande locale et donc
de légitimer ce type de construction par
rapport aux critiques récurrentes que
nous connaissons tous sur le
terrain madame la ministre mes chers
collègues il serait absurde et
inconcevable de vouloir réformer la
France en se coupant des mers des élus
locaux des villes et des village qui
sont la clé du bienvvre quotidien de
leurs habitants le lien de confiance
entre les élus locaux et l'État a été
fortement et durablement
endommagé le temps est venu de recréer
des ponts entre les collectivités
territoriales et l'exécutif à l'évidence
la PPL qui nous est présentée
aujourd'hui s'inscrit parfaitement dans
cette démarche et je la soutiens
pleinement merci de votre attention
merci la parole est à présent à notre
collègue André richichard pour le groupe
les républicains pour 4
[Applaudissements]
minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues les municipalités
communales restent depuis leur création
le lieu de l'intégration à l'État nation
et de la consolidation du lien politique
aujourd'hui plus que jamais l'existence
même de ce lien politique ne peut se
concevoir sans lien social ni plus
encore sans pouvoir municipal de toute
évidence le rôle les maires à cet égard
est non seulement logique mais aussi
crucial logique tout d'abord car c'est
sur les maires que repose Infiné
l'exécution des politiques du logement
qu'il s'agisse entre autres des demandes
de permis de construire et de la
construction de logements sociaux du
traitement des demandes fondées sur
dalallau des relogements prioritaires
toute politique du logement ne peut se
concevoir sans l'intervention de nos
maires c'est d'autant plus le cas
lorsque des objectifs sont assignés à
cette action chacun connaît à cet égard
les difficultés soulevées par l'article
55 de la loi SRU de 2000 imposant à
certaines communes de disposer d'un
nombre minimum de logements sociaux
chacun sait plus encore aujourd'hui
l'impact de la crise du BTP sur la
réalisation des objectif assignés aux
communes et tout élu municipal c'est
enfin le poids des contraintes
procédurales imposées par l'exercice du
droit de préemption l'apport de terrain
ou la garantie d'emprunt il faut donc à
cet égard que la simple participation
des maires aux commissions d'attribution
des logements est une sorte de minimum
garanti par la loi dont il faut
naturellement se débarrasser en effet
comment ne pas assurer au maire au stade
de l'élaboration des logements sociaux
une place d'importance égale à son
action dans la construction et la
construction des logements la garantie
apportée par l'article unique de la
présente loi qui propose de confier la
présidence des commissions au maire
concne non seulement l'association des
mairres aux politiques du logement mais
aussi leur efficacité et leur
investissement dans une action qui est
avant tout celle des communes tout
autant voire même plus que de l'État il
faut évidemment repousser les critiques
faciles dont toute procédure de
sélection et d'attribution SAAv passible
celle qui naissent des soupçons de
favoritisme et de clientélisme mes
collègues àair l'ont dit avant moi
accorderz une place prééminente au maire
dans l'attribution des logements sociaux
ne crée pas plus de risqu structurel de
décisions Solitair dans ce domaine
qu'ailleurs la décision d'attribution
est toujours communale et demeure donc
collective enfin plus encore qu'un enjeu
de politique publique le rôle du maire
dans l'attribution des logements et
surtout une question cruciale de
proximité mes chers collègues nous
sommes nombreux ici à avoir eu l'honneur
d'exercer les fonctions de maire nous
savons d'expérience pense que ce rôle ne
peut se concevoir sans la connaissance
approfondie de la population communale
de ses spécificités et des circonstances
locales qui la font vivre c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous devons
conserver et développer tous les outils
à disposition des maires pour favoriser
la pleine connaissance de leurs
administrés la mairie et les services
municipaux constituent le centre de
gravité du lien social depuis ses
origines c'est-à-dire dès l'arrivée des
nouveaux administrés dans une commune en
tant qu'élu du Barin donc
alsacien je rappelle à cet égard
l'existence d'une disposition de droit
local alsacien moseland prévoyant
l'obligation pour tout nouvel administré
de se déclarer en mairie afin d'y mettre
à jour le fichier domiciliaire
communal le non respect malheureusement
de cette obligation n'étant plus
sanctionné par une loi célérate de nos
jours il faut compter sur des
dispositifs spéciaux pour favoriser la
rencontre du maire et des des nouveaux
habitants de la commune l'attribution
des logements sociaux fait partie de ces
chemins mes chers collègues que les
représentants municipaux doivent
emprunter pour connaître leur population
pour ces raisons madame la ministre de
grâce n'attendons pas une hypothétique
loi de décentralisation qui si j'ai bien
compris ce que vous avez dit tout à
l'heure renforcera encore le rôle du
préfet à certains égards faisons mes
chers collègues dès aujourd'hui
confiance au maire et votons massivement
cette
PP
merci mes chers collègues la discussion
générale est close nous passons
désormais à la discussion du texte de la
commission
sur
l'article unique je suis saisi tout
d'abord d'un amendement numéro 9 de
notre collègue yanniic jado et je
précise qu'il y aura sur cet article une
demande de scrutin public monsieur mon
jade vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le Président
Madame la Ministre chers collègues à
travers cet amendement le groupe
écologie solidarité et territoire
s'oppose à l'instauration d'un droit de
véteau du maire sur l'attribution des
logements sociaux vous l'avez compris
nous ne comprenons pas comment un droit
de refus du maire qui serait de fait un
droit d'exclure renforce son pouvoir
d'attribution la question de la mixité
sociale est au cœur de l'attribution des
logements sociaux et la collégialité
constitue assurément un moyen de limiter
les risques de clientélisme et de
détournement de pouvoir c'est pour ça
que ça a été mis en œuvre en mettant
ainsi le maire au cœur du dispositif
pour orienter la question du peuplement
dans le parc social nous risquons de
faire peser une pression encore plus
forte sur le mer et de le mettre en
difficulté y compris quand nous allons
débattre après de la protection des élus
un droit de véau en lieu et place de
l'actuelle voie prépondérante en cas de
partage des voix ne nous semble donc pas
être le bon levier vous l'avez compris à
enin baaumont comme ailleurs nous
craignons que cette prérogative porte
les risques de clientélisme et de
discrimination ethnique religieuse et
sociale ce sont d'abord les enjeux de
transparence d'équité et d'objectivité
des critères liés à la représentativité
des bailleurs sociaux au sein de caleéol
qu'il convient de garantir le travail du
maire et bien de pouvoir créer une
vision et d'avoir les informations clés
qui permettent de créer une sociologie
de la ville mais pas d'exclure c'est
pourquoi nous demandons la suppression
de cet article unique
merci j'ai donc été saisi d'une demande
de scrutin public
sur Oui je le
demander je vais donc demander l'avis de
la commission madame la
Présidente
je pense monsieur jado puisque c'est
vous qui avez présenté cet amendement
que vous allez très rapidement apprendre
à comprendre comment on travaille ici
dans cet hémicycle et qu'il faut vous
garder des anathèmes des
caricatures et des raccourcis qui sont
un peu faciles ici nous avons tous sur
les bandes dehémicycle nos propres
convictions nous partageons pour
certains d'entre nous des valeurs nous
les respectons les uns les autres mais
nous refusons ce genre vective d'un
athème comme vous venez de le de le
faire assez de façon assez réductrice
dans votre amendement parce que dire ici
comme à1 Béon comme ailleurs c'est
vraiment des réflexions que vous ne
devriez pas utiliser dans l'enceinte de
cet
[Applaudissements]
hémicycle pour autant je me permets
d'apporter mon avis sur votre
proposition d'amendement qui cela ne
vous étonnera pas est un avis favorable
puisque'à travers cet amendement vous
voulez supprimer l'article unique de la
proposition de loi et donc supprimer
carrément la proposition de loi de
madame Sophie prima à laquelle nous
sommes attachés nous venons pour un
certain nombre d'entre nous de le
démontrer parce qu'elle vise
effectivement à redonner la main au
maire dans les commissions d'attribution
de logements sociaux pour éviter aussi
encore tout amalgame mais je pense qu'on
aura l'occasion d'y revenir
malheureusement dans un certain nombre
d'autres amendement que vous proposerez
le droit de vetto vous faites une
fixation sur ce droit de vetto
aujourd'hui effectivement il y a une
voie prépondérante pour le maire en cas
d'égalité de voie il faut d'abord savoir
que cette voie prépondérante elle est
très peu utilisée d'autre part cette
voie prépondérante il y a pas
l'obligation de la motiver et bien en
mettant en œuvre ce droit de vetto nous
confortons d'abord une base légale au
fait de pouvoir s'opposer effectivement
à un dossier de demande de logement qui
pour le maire ne lui semblerait pas
correspondre au vu de critères
parfaitement républicains au vu de la
qualification de la demande de logement
social telle qu'elle est établie par
l'Union Sociale de l'habitat qui n'est
pas opposé à la mise en place d'un droit
de veto contrairement à ce que les uns
et les autres ont dit sur ces través et
donc ce droit de veto on lui donne une
base légale mais ce droit de veto il est
vraiment utilisé Infiné comme l'ont dit
un certain nombre de mes collègues je
crois que c'est Laurence Garnier qui a
fait référence c'est que le droit de
vetto le maire il est responsable avant
tout il sait avant tout qu'il a all logé
un certain nombre de personnes sur sa
commune et que bien évidemment son
intérêt c'est de pouvoir apporter des
réponses au mieux àes aux attentes de
ses habitants et donc il va pas utiliser
son véau de façon discrétionnaire de
façon arbitraire au contraire on lui
donne une base légale il faut qu'il le
motive donc c'est au vu de l'ensemble
des critères sur lesquels il s'appuiera
pour pour éventuellement rejeter le
dossier demandeattribution mais moi je
vois surtout dans ce droit de vetto un
pouvoir de négociation du maire qui est
donné avant de faire jouer le droit de
vetto c'est-à-dire que sachant qu'il y a
un droit de vetto et bien le maire avec
l'ensemble des membres de la commission
d'ribution va pouvoir négocier le plus
le plus précisément possible et donc
affiner sa décision en but ultime donc
la vie est défavorable sur cet
amendement merci avis du gouvernement
madame la ministre merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Sénateur jade le
président de la République comme je l'ai
dit tout à l'heure annoncé vouloir
renforcer le contrôle des attributions
de logement sociaux par les maires afin
qu'ils puissent apporter toute leur
expertise ça a été beaucoup dit ici dans
cet hémicycle qui puisse apporter toute
leur expertise de terrain en matière de
peuplement de logement et d'habitat
c'est l'objet de cette proposition de
loi renforcer le pouvoir du maire quant
aux attributions effectuées dans sa
commune votre amendement est un
amendement de suppression en bloc de
cette PPL nous ne pouvons pas y
souscrire le gouvernement porte des
amendements à cette PPL que nous
qualifions de pertinente mais on veut
mieux l'encadrer et on veut améliorer le
texte par les amendements que nous vous
proposons juste après l'avis du
Gouvernement est donc
défavorable je vais donc mettre
oui monsieur
Guay merci monsieur le Président Madame
la mes chers collègues nous allons nous
voter la proposition d'amendement de nos
collègues écologistes et porté par Yan
jado il y a une question quand même à
laquelle pour l'instant ni madame la
rapporteur présidente ni nos collègues
de droite nont répondu c'est est-ce que
nous pensons que cette proposition de
loi portée par Madame primat va régler
la question du logement social je sais
vous nous avez dit non mais la la
principale question je vous pose à un
débat en sainsis je connais bien des
villes beaucoup de villes 8000
demandeurs de logement social dans une
ville 58000 habitants 200 à peu près
logement attribués le maire il en
attribue 20 même demain il va en
attribuer 100 ou 150 il va quand même
rester sur le carreau 7800 personne et
d'autant plus que ça va continuer à à
croître et c'est 8100 8200 et cetera et
cetera donc la question centrale c'est
la pénurie aujourd'hui et la pénurie de
construction donc la proposition que
vous nous faites elle doit s'inscrire
notamment dans la question du budget on
va laavir 10 milliards ont été
ponctionnés depuis 6 ans par le
gouvernement macroniste est-ce que nous
allons ici poser un acte ou nous allons
rendre les moyens aux bailleurs sociaux
de construire du logement social et de
répondre à la pénuie notamment
auentendus oui ou non faut qu'il y ait
des engagements aujourd'hui là parce que
le budget c'est pas dans c'est pas dans
dans 2 ans c'est dans un mois et on va
déjà on est déjà dans ce sujetl pénurie
de logement social pénurie on l'a dit
tout à l'heure un certain nombre de
sansabris 300 à 350000 donc il faut
qu'on ait un débat sur cette question
profitons de cette proposition loi pour
avoir ce débat est-ce que la droite
s'engage à revenir sur cette question
des 10 milliards et à donner les moyens
et là on verrez on sera bien plus utile
au maire de nos collectivités que en
adoptant cette proposition de loi
merci je vais donc ouvrir le scrutin en
vous rappelant le double avis
défavoraable de la commission et du
gouvernement sur cet amendement de
suppression le scrutin est
ouvert
personne ne demande à
voter
personne ne demande à voter le scrutin
est
clos sur cet amendement de suppression
votant 345 exprimé 345 pour 99 contre
246 cet amendement de suppression n'est
pas adopté
je suis saisi de plusieurs amendements
faisons l'objet d'une
discussion commune et je vais donner la
parole à Madame la Ministre pour un
amendement numéro 11 du gouvernement
merci monsieur le Président alors notre
amendement traite de la présidence des
caléoles il complète les dispositions
adoptées en commission des affaires
économiques pour le cas où la caléole
n'est réunie ni à l'échelle de la
commune ni à l'échelle de le PCI nous
proposons un amendement qui conserve la
présidence du maire lorsque la caléole
est réunie à l'échelle de la commune et
celle du président de le PCI lorsque le
PCI a demandé qu'elle soit réunie à son
échelle ce fonctionnement est celui
introduit par la commission des affaires
économiques pour les autres cas non
traités par la CAE l'amendement prévoit
une présidence tournante entre les
maires en cas d'absence d'un maire le
président sera comme aujourd'hui choisi
parmi les membres de la caléol désigné
par le
bailleur
merci
amendement numéro 1 monsieur buis merci
Président mes chers collègues cette
solution à travers cet amendement
permettrait de renforcer le rôle des
maires et des conseillers municipaux
dans l'attribution des logements sociaux
ce qui est l'objectif de ce texte sans
instaurer un droit de véto dont la
proposition de loi ne permet pas de
s'assurer que la mise en œuvre
opérationnelle ne suscitera pas de
nouvelles difficultés pour les maires
aussi nous proposons d'instaurer pour
les trois membres de la caléol
représentant la commune le principe de
deux voix pour chaque
représentant merci Monsieur buis
amendement suivant le 7 rectifier bis
monsieur Cabanel merci monsieur le
Président si vous le permettez je
défendrai les deux en même temps je
rappelle que les enjeux de la politique
d'attribution des logements sociaux sont
un meilleur accès des ménages les plus
défavorisés au parc social et une
meilleure mixité sociale des villes et
des quartiers l'habitat et le logement
sont au cœur d'un projet de territoire
que ce soit par la production de
logement ou par le peuplement or pour
que la politique d'attribution des
logements sociaux soit partagée et
efficace elle ne peut-être définie que
sur un plan local mais aussi sur le
fondement du cadre national posé par les
textes législatifes et réglementaires il
revient donc à nous de définir ces
orientations mais dont la mise en œuvre
ne peut se faire sans le partenariat de
l'état des bailleurs sociaux des
réservataires et des associations par
ces amendements je vise ainsi à
préserver le caractère collégial
républicain et objectif de la mise en
œuvre de la politique locale de
l'habitat et par conséquent de
l'attribution de ses logements sociaux
en effet le droit de véto accordé au
maire lors des réunions de la caléol
n'est pas un renforcement de son pouvoir
comme je l'ai pu le le dire dans la
discussion générale ainsi donc mon
premier amendement vise à renforcer le
rôle de la commune au sein de la Caléo
et leur et le de leur processus donc de
de validation et le deuxème amendement
est est un amendement de repli par
rapport donc pour revenir sur le loi de
vetto tel que apporté par un amendement
dans la PPL merci Monsieur Cabanel j'en
conclu que le 6 rectifié est
défendu amendement numéro 12 madame la
ministre merci monsieur le
Président donc cet amendement limite à
une fois par logement ne ou libérer le
droit de veto du maire introduit par la
commission des affaires économiques il
précise aussi que la caléole doit
s'appuyer sur les demandes et
informations enregistrées dans le
système national d'enregistrement de la
demande de logement
social je m'arrête là ça me paraî assez
clair merci Madame la Ministre enfin
amendement numéro 3 monsieur
Guay
oui merci monsieur le président madame
la ministre mes chers collègues on
revient sur le droit de vetto on propose
de
supprimer le droit de
veto pour deux raisons la
première c'est que j'ai posé la question
en commission
qu'adevient-il d'une famille qui se
voit émettre un veto par une commission
et en quelque part son parcours dans le
logement social se voit stopper net
parce que imaginez-vous bien que sur une
ville a si une famille a obtenu un
véteau d'un mer il va être assez
complexe pour elle d'aller dans la ville
B C ou D et de demander à nouveau un
logement social si je peux me permettre
cette expression elle sera ficher rouge
et donc pour le coup son parcours dans
le logement social est évidemment euh
fermé la deuxième pour revenir sur un
débat qui a été introduit tout à l'heure
par
Yannick moi je ne crois pas que tous les
élus soient clientélistes pas du tout et
personne ne peut dire ça et d'ailleurs
il ne l'a pas dit mais il peut exister
des
dérives partout par exemple dans le
logement privé je ne parle pas du
logement social dans le logement privé
un certain nombre d'association on fait
du testing et dans l'attribution du
logement privé il existe à % dans les
testings des choses discriminatoires
donc la question si on met un droit de
vetto pour s'en prémunir c'est tout le
l'argument de l'amendement 4 nous
proposons nous proposons donc
d'anonymiser en réalité les demandes de
logement comme c'est fait à Paris depuis
2014 ce qui nous prémunérait de
potentiels dérivve qui pourrait arriver
même si elles sont minoritaires voilà
donc notre opposition complète au droit
de vet je vous en remercie merci sur ces
amendements faisant l'objet d'une
discussion commune je vais demander
l'avis de la commission madame la
Présidente merci monsieur le Président
alors sur les amendements du
Gouvernement je répondrai d'abord donc
l'amendement numéro 11 et l'amendement
numéro 12 on regrette que il y a des
précisions qui sont utiles dans les deux
amendements que vous venez de présenter
madame la ministre sauf que pour autant
il y a certains points de la proposition
de loi tel que nous l'avons rapporté en
commission et et voté que vous supprimez
et donc ce qui explique aussi que sur
ces deux amendements mon avis sera un
avis défavorable c'est dommage parce que
les précisions que vous apportez en
particulier dans dans l'amendement
numéro 11 qui mentionne la possibilité
d'une présidence tournante et envisage
le cas où effectivement la commune ne
serait pas représentée ce qui peut tout
à fait se passer ce serit alors au
bailleur social de la présidé donc
précision utile mais dans le même
amendement euh vous mentionner également
vous supprimez le droit de véau du maire
et donc ça vous l'aurez bien compris que
nous ne voulons absolument pas que ce
droit de véau soit supprimé donc c'est
le même amendement sur l'amendement
numéro 12 vous traitez également de
trois sujets différents et sur ces trois
sujets différents un vous limitez le
droit de veto à une seule fois par
logement moi je pense que c'est
finalement dénaturé complètement le
droit de veto que de le limiter et de
dire le maire ne pourra utiliser son
droit de veto qu'une seule fois c'est le
restreindre c'est prendre le risque
aussi d'en faire finalement un sabre de
bois facilement contournable parce que
on se dira si le maire ne peut utiliser
qu'une qu'une seule fois ce droit de
vetto bien on va attendre la prochaine
fois la prochaine commissionattribution
pour présenter le di dossier et donc là
le maire ne pourra plus faire jouer son
droit de veto et en l'occurrence le di
dosier pourra à ce moment-là être retenu
contre la vie du maire donc c'est par
contre quand vous dites que la
Commission doit se fonder sur les
demandes inscrites dans le système
national d'enregistrement ça me semble
effectivement être une précision utile
et une précision qui la bienvenu sauf
qu'elle se trouve englobée dans cet
amendement numéro 12 et que comme nous
voulons maintenir le droit de veto et
donc nous ne pouvons pas vous donner un
avis favorable sur cet amendement numéro
12 sur les amendement suivant
l'amendement de Monsieur Bui qui propose
une alternative au droit de veto qui est
créé par la commission donc là vous avez
compris là aussi qu'on souhaite garder
ce droit de veto et que si on a écarté
la solution que vous proposé à savoir
une représentation par le maire et par
deux délégués du conseil municipal c'est
parce qu'on pense que en sollicitant
fréquemment les élus et avec un poids
inégal suivant la taille de la commune
parce que c'est vrai que c'est plus
facile peut-être dans les grandes villes
de pouvoir se faire représenter et dans
les plus petites communes si le maire
n'est pas là ou si son représentant ne
peut pas venir donc on pense qu'on
apporte finalement qu'une question
partielle et que ça va poser la question
de la disponibilité des élus communaux
ainsi que du maire avec des problèmes de
Corum quand on sait qu'aujourd'hui il y
a des commissions d'attribution qui
régulièrement se passent maintenant
pratiquement tous les 15 jours donc on
imagine combien cela peut effectivement
poser de problème et reporter d'autant
la commissionattribution et donc la
nonattribution de logement dans les
délais impartis l'amendement numéro 7 et
numéro de Henry Cabanel je le cherchais
donc là aussi vous vous différenciez de
l'amendement de Monsieur Bui par le fait
que vous n'accorderez pas de droit de
vote au double au représentants de la
commune et que le troisième représentant
serait pas nécessairement un membre de
l'opposition municipale et dans
l'amendement 6 de repli vous distinguez
les deux précédents en ne proposant que
la suppression du droit de vetto et le
rétablissement de la voie prépondérante
donc là je crois que j'ai déjà répondu
nous souhaitons conserver le droit de V
et nous pensons que la voie
prépondérante aujourd'hui n'est pas de
nature à redonner de la confiance au
maire parce qu'elle est encore une fois
très peu utilisé et en plus quand elle
est utilisée elle n'est même pas motivée
alors que nous faisons du droit de veto
avec véritablement dûent motivé enfin
l'amendement numéro 3 de mon collègue
Fabien Guay et bien puisqu'il porte
intégralement sur le droit de véau
charfabien ça sera un avis défavorable
je ne pense pas que la personne qui aura
fait l'objet d'un droit de véau par le
maire en fonction de critères de
qualification de la demande de logement
social donc qui sont des critères
républicains qui sont établis dans un
vadmcom fait par l'Union Sociale de
l'habitat donc le maire s'appuiera sur
de tels critères pour dire qu'il motive
son droit de vé à partir d'un ou
plusieurs de ces critères mais ce n'est
pas pour autant que le demandeur de
logement social qui n'aura qui aura été
évincé à travers le droit de veto sera
marqué de d'une d'une croix voilà et
dira parce que encore une fois c'est sur
un logement donné un logement donné ça
veut dire que le demandeur qui sera
repositionné sur un autre logement et
bien pourra faire l'objet d'une
attribution parce que peut-être que si
le veto a joué sur un logement donné au
vu de sa composition familiale au vu de
la résidence dans lequelle se trouve le
quartier au vu de la stabilité ou non de
la résidence en question mais ça
s'appliquera pas pour l'attribution du
même d'un autre logement au même
demandeur de logement social donc avis
défavorable merci madame la Présidente
avis du gouvernement madame la
ministre alors en toute cohérence avec
la présentation que j'ai faite de des
deux amendements du Gouvernement je
demande euh l'amendement 1 2 et 3 euh au
1 2 et 6 pardon euh aux sénateurs qui
les ont porter de bien vouloir les
retirer au profit de l'amendement du
Gouvernement euh 11 et quant au sénateur
Guay euh pour ce qui est de l'amendement
3 je vous demande si vous voulez bien le
retirer au profit de notre amendement 12
je vous remercie
ok c'est
bon alors je suis saisi de deux
explications deux demandes d'explication
de vote Monsieur
stanzion Merci monsieur le Président
Madame la Ministre
C l' fait une dizaine d'années que le
législateur régule l'organisation et la
gouvernance des commissions
d'attribution des logements les acteurs
de la chaîne d'attribution sont dotés
d'outils même si ceci se reste
perfectible mais l'objectif est bien de
favoriser la concertation en amont entre
les acteurs et d'assurer l'impartialité
des commission nous nous ne sommes pas
favorables de retirer la présidence des
des commission d'attribution aux
organismes d'HLM donc vous l'aurez
compris nous voterons contre l'ensemble
de vos amendements merci merci Monsieur
Guay
oui merci monsieur le président madame
la ministre je vous répond on n'enlèvera
pas notre amendement euh au profit du
vôre je crois qu'il est pas tout à fait
de la même nature
euh deuxièmement juste une question à
madame la Présidente rapporteur sur le
droit de vetto j'ai compris il faudra
qu'il soit motivé très bien mais les
critères parce que il va avoir des
critères est-ce qu'ils seront
discrétionnaire pour chaque mèire où il
va avoir une liste de critères
c'est-à-dire par exemple ça sera sur la
question des revenus la composition des
ménages s'il est de la localité ou pas
par exemple on pourra plus facilement
refuser quelqu'un qui n'habite pas la
commune qu'une autre voyez il faut faut
qu'on comme là vous introduisez quelque
chose en commission on n pas eu le temps
de palper ce que ça va donner dans le
réel faut que vous abondiez un peu ce
que vous voulez faire ce droit de
critère discrétionnaire pour chacun et
donc là ça ouvre des
portes quand même ou alors ça sera à
partir de critères bien établis
motivé voyez madame la Présidente
rapporteur si vous pouvez nous éclairer
sur cette question ça changera pas
fondamentalement notre vote nous
voterons contre le droit de vetto mais
ça nous en dira un peu plus sur votre
projet je vous remercie madame la
Présidente je c avoir était assez clair
mais donc voilà il y a un document qui
existe aujourd'hui qui est à la
disposition de tous les élus locaux et
donc de tous les maires quel que soit le
territoire sur lequel ces élus locaux
ont leur responsabilité et qui concerne
la qualification du parc social et de
son occupation et à la fin de cette de
ce document il y a effectivement une
présentation des différents critères qui
permettent de pouvoir étayer motiver un
refus et vous avez voilà des ça peut
être
effectivement par rapport à la au revenu
ça peut être par rapport à les familles
monoparentales des personnes seules des
regardez le revenu le loyer les données
de cadrage les activités des majeurs
l'aide au logement donc à partir de cela
et dans le cadre de l'ensemble de ces
indicateurs qui sont des indicateurs
prioritaires généralement le maire qui
aura ce qui sera amené à donner son
droit de vetto s'appuiera sur ces
critères qui sont aujourd'hui la base
pour qualifier toute demande de logement
social pour pouvoir dire et bien sur
cette résidence au regard du logement
qui est proposé je considère que
l'indicateur qui est en lien avec le
loyer avec les revenus du ménage ne
correspond pas au logement que l'on veut
attribuer à cette famille à ce ménage
donc je pense que c'est très clair et
que c'est important aussi de savoir que
cela existe je suis pas sûr
effectivement que l'ensemble des des
élus locaux et des maires connaissent ce
document qui a établi par l'Union
Sociale de l'habitat mais c'est vraiment
la base de référence pour motiver demain
un droit de vetto que le maire ferait
jouer merci madame la Présidente je vais
donc mettre au vote ces six amendements
qui ont fait l'objet d'une discussion
commune en commençant par l'amendement
numéro ah Monsieur buit me ditons pour
une explication de
vote merci président c'était pour dire
tout simplement que je retirais mon
amendement au Provis de celui du
gouvernement donc l'amendement numéro 1
est
retiré sur l'amendement numéro 11 du
gouvernement avec un avis défavorable de
la commission je mets au vote qui est
pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté sur l'amendement 7 rectifié bis
avec un avis défavorable de la
commission une demande de retrait ou à
des fois un avis défavorable du
gouvernement je mets au voix qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient il
n'est pas adopté
sur l'amendement 6 rectifié de notre
collègue Cabanel avec un avis
défavorable de la commission une demande
de retrait ou à des fois un avis
défavorable du gouvernement qui est
pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté sur l'amendement 12 du
gouvernement avec un avis défavorable de
la commission je mets au voix qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient il
n'est pas pas adopté enfin sur
l'amendement numéro 3 notre collègue
Fabien Guay avec un avis défavorable de
la commission à une demande de retrait
ou à défaut un avis défavorable du
gouvernement qui est
pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté amendement
suivant le de rectif
monsieur
foissin merci monsieur le président
madame la présidente madame la ministre
cet amendement propose d'intégrer à la
commission d'attribution des logements
et d'examen de l'occupation des
logements la fameuse caléole un
conseiller départemental élu au sein du
conseil départemental avec voix
consultative il s'agit ici d'intégrer
l'expertise des départements en matière
d'accompagnement social ainsi que leur
connaissance pratique des difficultés
que peuvent rencontrer les demandeurs au
sein de de la caléole il s'agit
également de reconnaître au département
son rôle de soutien dans la construction
des logements sociaux par exemple à
travers la délégation de compétences
pour l'attribution des aides à la pierre
ainsi que son rôle direct de soutien aux
populations en difficultés dans leur
logement via les fonds de solidarité
pour le logement je vous remercie je
vais demander l'avis de la commission
madame la
Présidente merci monsieur le Président
donc sur cet amendement numéro 2
rectifié l'avis sera un avis favorable
en effet même si les services sociaux
départementaux peuvent d'ors et déjà
aujourd'hui être largement consultés
cette participation ne paraît pas
inutile le fait que l'on puisse intégrer
à titre consultatif un membre du conseil
départemental à l'intérieur des caléoles
parce que effectivement les conseils
départementaux donc sont aussi parties
prenantes parfois dans la construction
de logements sociaux mais dans la
politique de l'habitat et notamment ils
ont souvent aussi en charge la
définition du plan départemental
d'action pour le logement et
l'hébergement des personnes défavorisées
le PDA lhpd et donc à ce titre-là je
considère qu'effectivement cette
participation avec une voie consultative
ne modifie pas les équilibres
prévisionnel de la décisionnelle pardon
de la caléole n'est pas de nature non
plus à alourdir le fonctionnement c'est
la raison pour laquelle j'ai décidé de
donner un avis favorable à votre
amendement merci madame la présidente
madame la ministre merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Sénateur foissin
actuellement le président de la caléol
peut déjà appeler à siéger à titre
consultatif un représentant du service
chargé de l'action sanitaire et sociale
du conseil départemental en application
de l'article R 441-9 du code de la
construction et de l'habitation le
présent amendement fait de ce
représentant un membre à part entière de
la caléole qui dispose d'un droit de
vote cette proposition est cohérente
avec le R de chef de fil du du conseil
départemental en matière d'action
sociale et avec son rôle en matière
d'élaboration et de mise en œuvre du
plan départemental d'action pour le
logement et l'hébergement des personnes
défavorisées c'est pourquoi le
gouvernement amet un avis favorable sur
votre
amendement merci madame la ministre je
suis saisi d'une demande d'explication
de vote de notre collègue Denis
BOAD merci monsieur le Président je suis
gêné sur cet amendement pour avoir
exercé depuis de nombre dornis exercer
encore un rôle de conseil départemental
je serais plutôt favorable mais je lis
cet amendement et il me gêne et je lis
il s'agit également de reconnaître au
département son rôle de soutien dans la
construction de logements sociaux c'est
très bien par exemple à travers la
délégation à la pierre par l'attribution
des aides à la pierre ainsi que par le
rôle direct au soutien des populations
en difficulté madame la ministre vous
l'avait rappelé on aurait pu rajouter
dans cet amendement les garanties
d'emprunt ce qui fait pour pour le
département des dépenses pas des
dépenses mais un investissement qui est
énorme alors comment peut-on imaginer
qu'on demande à un conseil départemental
de venir siéger deux fois par semaine
dans mon département dans d'autres
organismes une fois de plus ça fera
plusieurs fois par semaine où conseiller
départemental délégué va aller siéger
dans ces commissions avec une voie
consultative quand dans le même temps il
a apporté du financement de la garantie
d'emprunt et du soutien au plus
défavorisé donc donc pour cette
raison-là et avec beaucoup de regret mon
groupe votre RAC
compte merci je vais donc soumettre au
vote cet amendement de rectifier qui a
obtenu un double avis favorable de la
commission et du
gouvernement qui est
pour qui est
contre qui
s'abstient il est adopté
amendement numéro 4 monsieur
Guay euh merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
on en a parlé tout à l'heure je vais
faire très court c'est une
expérimentation que nous demandons de
pousser mais ça sera peut-être le moment
dans un débat bien plus large sur la
question du logement sur la question de
l'anonymisation ce qui permet toujours
de connaître la composition du ménage et
les revenus donc il y a les besoins et
les moyens pour pouvoir choisir mais qui
permet
notamment au demandeurs de ne pas subir
dans des rares cas mais ça peut arriver
quelle que soit la discrimination donc
nous proposons cette question très vrai
semblablement elle sera refusée mais
nous y reviendrons sur un débat bien
plus large sur le logement social je
vous remercie merci avis de la
commission madame la
Présidente bien vu monsieur Guay
effectivement l'amendement reçoit un
avis
défavorable l'anonymisation existe déjà
pour les demandeurs elle est protégé
juste avant la caléole les éléments
personnels à ce moment-là n'étant pas
transmis lors de la convocation de la
Commission en revanche effectivement les
caractéristiques socio-économiques les
motivations de la demande les éléments
qui sont relatifs à l'identité du
demandeur et à la composition familiale
sont logiquement examinés par la
commission alors derrière ce cache
effectivement vous le dites des craintes
de discrimination d'accès au logement au
regard du nom j'ose penser que
véritablement c'est des cas qui ne se
produisent aujourd'hui pratiquement pas
ou plus et que donc c'est bien d'avoir
une certaine anonymisation en amont mais
c'est bien aussi qu'au moment de la
convocation de la commission les membres
de la commission et l'ensemble des
éléments à leur disposition pour pouvoir
prendre la décision qui soit la plus
adéquate possible au regard du logement
qui est proposé merci madame la
présidente madame la ministre avis du
gouvernement merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Sénateur
gay le gouvernement euh est lui aussi
très inquiet devant le constat établi
par SOS Racisme de l'existence d'une
discrimination liée à la consonance
étrangère des noms pour l'attribution
des logements sociaux il s'agit d'un
sujet très sérieux et différentes
analyses demeurent en cours avec à la
fois l'ushh et le je
SNE système national d'enregistrement
l'instance qui enregistre la demande de
logement social pour mieux le comprendre
et pour essayer d'y apporter les
meilleurs remèdes dans les médias il
nous semble que la solution que vous
proposez n'atteindra pas sa cible en
effet ce n'est pas l'attribution d'après
nous monsieur le sénateur qui doit être
rendu anonyme je ne pense pas qu'on
puisse attribuer un logement à quelqu'un
sans le nommer mais c'est bien le
dossier qui sera amené à être proposé
par le réservateur ou le bailleur
d'abord puis examiné par la caléole
ensuite or le bailleur a une obligation
de vérification et d'instruction du
dossier après que la candidature a été
présentée par le
réservataire bien souvent il organise
même une visite des lieux pour minimiser
les risques de refus dans ce contexte
l'anonymation ne peut intervenir que
très tardivement dans le processus et
garantir réellement l'anonymat ne peut
être qu'une gageure à ce stade et même
si nous sommes conscient qu'il existe
des expériences d'anonymation des
dossiers présentés en caléol nous ne
sommes pas que la pratique puisse être
généralisée sans un énorme travail à
Mont avec les représentants de la
profession c'est pourquoi malgré toute
l'importance du sujet que vous soulevez
et la nécessité d'un débat je vous
propose que vous retiriez votre
amendement dans le cas contraire le
gouvernement émettra un avis de rejet de
la part du gouvernement merci madame la
ministre je vais mettre au voix cet
amendement
ah Monsieur gu pour explication de
vote monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre donc soit il y a un problème
soit il y en a pas non mais et vous nous
dites il y a un problème et des
associations le reconnaissent bon très
bien nous on vous on vous fait une
proposition
l'anonymisation je le redis c'est que le
nom qui est
caché pas la composition pas les revenus
moi je suis un désaccord avec la présid
re rapporteur qu'est-ce que le nom nous
rajoute dans la composition à part si on
connaît tous les demandeurs de logement
social de Saville je vous souhaite bon
courage ou alors il faut y passer du
temps voyez déjà je connais pas les 348
sénateurs par leur prénom s'il faut que
je connaisse les 8000 demandur de
logement social de ma ville je vais y
passer des heures et des heures donc la
question du nom n'est pas un plus pour
attribuer un logement on est d'accord
oui on est d'accord puisqu'on ne le
connaît pas donc il s'appelle Pascal
savold pierre Baros ou Fabien gu ça n'a
aucune conséquence puisquon le connaît
pas donc la seule question oui enfin si
pour Pascal ça a une conséquence mais
non mais plus plus sérieusement ça n'a
aucune conséquence donc il n'y a que la
composition du ménage les revenus et
d'autres éléments voyez ouais non mais
on peut pousser un peu le débat donc on
peut pas dire il a un problème mais
finalement c'est pas le sujet mais quand
même un peu sinon vous êtes en
contradiction avec ce que avec ce que
vous dites donc nous on dit il y a un
problème regardons-le sérieusement on
fait une proposition et par exemple la
mairie de Paris le fait donc quand même
c'est pas c'est la mairie de Paris avec
des centaines et des centaines elle fait
des choses donc c'est à regarder de près
on est d'accord madame la ministre je
vous remercie on continuera à avoir ce
débat merci Madame Goulet pour
explication de vote oui moi monsieur le
Président je vais voter cet amendement
j'ai c'était pas un logement social mais
nous avons un collègue dans cette maison
qui a eu un certain nombre de problèmes
de de racisme on peut dire ça comme ça
lorsqu'il est devenu sénateur et qu'il a
voulu un appartement près du Sénat on le
lui a refusé en raison de son de son nom
et et ça a fait d'ailleurs un certain
nombre de de Gorg et c'était normal
d'ailleurs il y a eu un certain nombre
de remous sur le sujet moi je trouve que
c'est une très bonne solution et moi je
la
voterai merci Madame prima Sophie prima
pour explication de
vote comme je l'ai dit tout à l'heure
moi je ne vois pas en tout cas dans la
vallée de Scine dont je suis l'habitante
dans une vallée de scinene qui comprend
un certain nombre de communes dans
lequel il y a une mixité très importante
de nationalité 32 dans ma commune je ne
vois pas cette discrimination au non je
comprends que vous disiez que les que
les associations le dénoncent donc il y
a peut-être un sujet mais je ne suis pas
sûre que ça soit la bonne solution donc
je vote
évidemment dans le sens de la rapporteur
et de Madame la Ministre et je voudrais
dire à Madame Goulet que notre ami
sénateur qui a connu une forme de
racisme sur son nom c'était sur un
appartement privé donc l'amendement que
propose ici notre collègue Fabien Guay
n'a aucun effet sur le cas malheureux de
notre
collègue merci je vais donc madame la
Présidente pour être un peu plus
présente pr précise sur ce sujet
aujourd'hui dans le code de la
construction et de l'habitat il est dit
la commission attribue
nominativement chaque logement locatif
donc ce que je comprends c'est que vous
souhaiteriez que l'on modifie quelque
part le code de la construction et de
l'habitat pour marquer chaque la
commission attribue
anonymement chaque logement locatif
c'est ça que vous souhaiteriez mettre en
place parce qu'aujourd'hui on peut pas
de fait on peut rendre anonyme les
dossiers en amont de la préparation de
la Caléo pour effectivement qu'ils
arrivent ensuite au moment de la de de
la discussion et d'attribution et alors
mais un logement il doit bien être
attribué nominativement en tout cas
c'est comme ça aujourd'hui que c'est
spécifié dans le code de la construction
et de
l'habitat merci je vais donc mettre au
voix cet amendement numéro 4 qui a
recueilli un avis défavorable de la
commission et une demande de retrait ou
à défaut un avis défavorable du
gouvernement qui est
pour qui est
contre qui
s'abstient il n'est pas adopté deux
amendements en discussion commune le
l'amendement numéro 5 monsieur Guay
oui merci monsieur le président madame
la ministre mes chers collègues je vous
avoue que là on n' pas bien compris
pourquoi ça a été introduit en
commission c'està-dire que sur le
logement neu non mais c'est un débat sur
le logement neuf donc là pas de Dallot
pas de personne en situation de handicap
suroccupation insalubrité violence
conjugale mais si si on on on met la
priorité que sur logement neuf en tout
cas on l'a compris comme ça vous allez
pouvoir nous l'expliciter
euh du coup tous ces cas-là qui ont déjà
du mal à rentrer dans un parcours
résidentiel et à avoir accès au logement
social en seront en seront plus
pénalisés d'autant plus que les
constructions neuves participent
évidemment à la réponse insuffisante
mais a une réponse en tout cas sur le
logement social donc si d'entrée on
exclut
un certain nombre de public ils auront
deux fois plus de mal à accéder à un
logement social donc nous proposons de
revenir sur cette question et de
supprimer cet alinéa je vous
remercie merci amendement numéro
13 présenté par le gouvernement madame
la
ministre merci monsieur le Président
donc notre amendement transforme en une
faculté l'obligation de délégation du
contingent de réservation voté par la
commission des affaires économiques je
vous ai expliqué la raison pour laquelle
on porte le fait que ça puisse être une
faculté non pas une obligation dans ma
déclaration générale cela corrige un
problème de coordination entre
différentes dispositions du code de la
construction et de l'habitation en
matière de
délégation merci je vais demander l'avis
de la commission madame la
Présidente alors sur ces deux
amendements l'avis sera bien évidemment
défavorable puisque c'est un des trois
leviers que nous avons voulu mettre en
exerg à travers cette proposition de loi
c'est-à-dire la possibilité pardon
c'est-à-dire la délégation automatique
du contingent de l'État au maire
lorsqu'il y a des attributions des
résidences neuves alors Monsieur Guay
fin de ne pas avoir très bien compris je
n'ose y croire Cher Fabien Guay je pense
que vous avez tout à fait bien compris
et c'est pas parce que que on déléguera
au maire le contingent de l'État en plus
de ce contingent communal que ne seront
pas loger dans cette résidence neuve des
Dallos des femmes victimes de violence
ou des personnes en difficulté sauf que
peut-être ça sera effectivement d'abord
et avant tout des personnes qui sont
déjà habitantes de la commune et que le
maire prioritairement voudra d'abord
loger ses propres habitants qui
aujourd'hui sont soit mal logés soit
hébergés soit dans la rue mais c'est pas
parce que on délégrait le contingent de
l'État que ces public dit publics
prioritaires que vous avez cité ne
pourront pas être logés dans la première
attribution par le maire qui disposera
effectivement sur les résidences neuves
grosso modo de la moitié des logements à
attribuer ensuite sur l'amendement du
Gouvernement l'amendement numéro 13
l'avis est un avis aussi défavorable
puisque vous voulez à travers votre
amendement transformer
l'automaticité en une simple faculté
nous nous voulons effectivement faire en
sorte que la délégation du contingent de
l'État au maire soit obligatoirement
transmise au maire et ne soit pas une
simple faculté parce que ça pourrait
être la discrétion à ce moment-là de
l'État et du préfet donc nous nous
voulons absolument conserver
l'automaticité et nous pensons
qu'effectivement sur des résidences
neuves qui peuvent entraider des
équilibre très rapidement au regard de
ménages qui sont en difficulté qui
pourraient déstabiliser la résidence
neuve qui est proposée à l'attribution
et bien le maire puisse à la fois
disposer de son propre contingent mais
également du contingent de l'État on l'a
dit dans la discussion générale ça se
pratique dans de nombreux territoires ça
marche bien et bien autant le
généraliser à travers une inscription
directement dans la loi et c'est un
motif pour nous de dire qu'il faut
davantage et toujours plus faire
confiance au
maire merci avis du gouvernement madame
la ministre merci monsieur le
Président sur l'amendement 5 du sénateur
gay le gouvernement n'est pas insensible
à l'argumentaire que vous déployez en
faveur des publics d'allau prioritaires
les plus défavorisés nous pensons que
dans certains cas la tentation peut
exister d'évincer ces public des
programmes neufs et que cela sera as
désastreux pour la solidarité nationale
pour autant nous avons fait le choix de
faire confiance aux maires qui bien
entendu dans leur immense majorité ne
sont pas insensibles non plus à la
question des publics prioritaires je
vais récapituler ici le sens de nos
différents amendements le gouvernement a
proposé trois modifications qui
devraient permettre de confirmer cette
confiance au maire et de sécuriser le
dispositif contre des tentatives
discrétionnaires qui ici ou là pourrait
exister à l'amendement 12 qui n'a pas
été adopté on proposait de remonter dans
la loi l'obligation de concertation pour
les logements 9 qui est aujourd'hui dans
le règlement et on conférait au maire un
rôle de co-organisateur de cette
concertation on limitait la faculté de
refus d'une candidature introduite dans
la commission des affaires économiques à
une seule fois pour chaque logement neuf
ou libéré dans l'amendement 13 on
propose de laisser le préfet analyser
localement la situation et
éventuellement de ne pas délégué s'il
estime son contingent s'il estime qu'il
existe un risque l'obligation de
délégation issue des travaux de la
commission est transformer tout
simplement en faculté à à l'amendement
14 il qui va venir nous introduisons des
obligations de motivation et de
transparence qui rendront impossible
tout abus ou toute décision
discrétionnaire avec ces trois
propositions clairement il ne sera
jamais possible de mener une politique
systématique de non de non tion au
public les plus défavorisés mais nous
n'abandonnons pas non plus l'idée que le
maire doit avoir un regard particulier
et asymétrique sur les attributions de
logement neuf donc je vous invite à
retirer comme je l'ai déjà fait tout à
l'heure votre proposition d'amendement
et à vootter les trois amendements le
premier a déjà pas été voté du
gouvernement mais je souhaitais
expliciter le sens de nos amendements je
vous propose donc de le retirer sinon
rejet merci
merci madame la ministre je suis saisi
d'une demande d'explication de vote
madame
Artigalas oui merci monsieur le
Président nous nous sommes plutôt
favorables à ces amendements parce que
mais on se on se pose la question de
pourquoi légiférer puisque cette
pratique existe déjà c'est-à-dire que
cette délégation au moment de la
livraison de l'immeuble est souvent
prévue dans les conventions de
réservation signées avec l'État voilà
nous donc nous n'y sommes pasos opposés
ça existe déjà par contre nous sommes
opposés à la à à cette que ça devienne
automatique bien évidemment sur les je
dirais dans les communes carancé de
laisser tous les logements neufs à
laadrtion du maire paraître quand même
un petit peu un petit peu enfin aller
trop loin là-dedans donc nous sommes
favorables à ce qui existe
déjà merci chers collègues je vais donc
mettre au voie ces deux amendements
ayant fait l'objet d'une discussion
commune en commence par l'amendement
numéro 5 de Monsieur Guay qui a reçu un
avis défavorable de la commission et un
avis défavorable ou à défaut une demande
un avis demande de retrait pardon ou à
défaut un avis défavorable du
gouvernement je mets au voix qui est
pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté sur l'amendement numéro 13 du
ouvernement qui a reçu un avis
défavorable de la commission je mets au
voix qui est
pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté alors je vais
maintenant procéder au vote sur
l'article ainsi amendé je ne vois pas de
demande application si Monsieur
Savoldelli merci monsieur le Président
Madame la Ministre madame la Présidente
débattre de la place des communes dans
l'attribution des logements sociaux bien
sûr encore faut-il qu'il y ait des
logements sociaux dans mon département
du Valdemar nous avons dépassé les
100000 demandeurs de logement jamais ce
chiffre n'avait jamais atteint jamais et
parmi eux combien sont pas solevables
donc non éligibl à l'attribution de
logement nulle part dans cette
proposition de loi il n'a été question
ici des demandeurs de logement ce
vocabulaire vous est étranger jamais et
pourtant le Congrès HLM a eu lieu la
semaine dernière les acteurs du logement
a on lancé une alerte il n'y a jamais
autant de demandeur de logement social
en France et dans le même temps na
jamais aussi peu produit de logements
sociaux moins de 85000 logements
construits à l'échelle nationale tout
cela ça vient pas de nulle part dès 2017
madame la ministre l'État a pris 1,3
milliard ver 7 des loyers des bailleurs
sociaux pour les réinjecter dans le
budget national de l'État le Sénat a eu
la possibilité d'y palier mais il l'a
pas fait et permettez-moi de revenir
quelques années en arrière mon collègue
alors sénateur Christian Favier avait
déposé une proposition de loi pour
qu'autour des gares du Grand Paris
Express soit 70000 logements construits
par an selon la Société du Grand Paris
il y ait 30 % de logements sociaux mais
la majorité sénatoriale a refusé de
rendre ce progrès possible c'était le 17
octobre 2016 et vous-même madame la
sénatrice prima vous étiez rapporteur au
nom de la commission et vous vous êtes
opposé à ce texte c'est tout à fait
logique idéologiquement mais
permettez-moi de questionner la volonté
véritable des auteurs de cette
proposition de loi quand on l'interroge
regard des votes précédents comme mon
groupe je voterai contre cet article
unique mais dans quelques semaines nous
nous retrouverons pour débattre du
projet de loi de finance pour l'année de
2024 je vous propose que le Sénat vote
la TVA à 5,5 % en faveur de la
construction sociale cela favoriserait
un objectif nécessaire de 200000
logements par an et je pense que là on
verra la vérité des votes et la vérité
des intentions on verra qui veut
rassembler les maires et tout le monde
dit le vouloir mais on rassemblera tous
les maires on rassemblera les bailleurs
et on rassemblera un vocabulaire qui
vous a étranger les demandeurs de
logement
merci merci chers collègues je vais donc
mettre au vote l'article ainsi amendé
qui est
pour qui est
contre qui
s'abstient il est
adopté après l'article unique je suis
saisi d'un amendement numéro 8 madame
mliman merci monsieur le président
madame le rapporteur madame la ministres
mes chers collègues permettez-moi de
m'associer en premier lieu aux orateurs
qui ont rappelé à quel point les
dispositions dont nous débattons visant
à renforcer le rôle du maire dans
l'attribution des logements sociaux dans
sa commune était attendu cet amendement
s'inscrit dans l'esprit du texte
renforcer le pouvoir des maires lors des
premières attributions sur un amme ne9u
tout en portant attention à la qualité
du dialogue au sein de la commission
d'attribution des logements et d'examen
de l'occupation des logements dites
caléol chacun sait que la première vague
de désignation sur un programme est un
moment clé qui permet d'agir
concrètement sur l'habitat d'une
résidence et d'un quartier sur son
équilibre et sa
cohésion en ce sens la délégation du
contingent préfect éoral au maire sur
les programmes neufs tels que prévu est
décisive mais il est également essentiel
que ces enjeux soi partagés par
l'ensemble des réservataires en amont de
la Caléo c'est pourquoi je vous propose
avec cet amendement de créer une
commission de concertation présidée par
le maire qui réunirait obligatoirement
tous les réservataire d'un programme
neuf avant sa livraison afin de
formaliser ce dialogue je vous
remercie merci chers collègues avis de
la commission madame la
Présidente ma cher collègue l'avis que
je vous donnerai à votre amendement est
un avis favorable vous proposez
effectivement de créer une commission de
concertation de suivi des programmes de
construction de logements sociaux
jusqu'à leur livraison cela me semble
aller dans le bon sens et être utile
pour la bonne insertion de ces
programmes bien évidemment dans le
quartier mais dans la commune plus
généralement et des futures populations
aujourd'hui c'est vrai qu'il existe déjà
ce type de commission de concertation
mais donc elles sont de la
responsabilité du bailleur pour la
première attribution là en l'occurrence
c'est le maire qui présiderait à cette
commission de concertation et qui
pourrait ainsi suivre tous les
programmes de construction jusqu'à leur
livraison et être à même véritablement
d'amener par rapport à un contexte local
tout ce qu'il faut pour que les
attributions se fassent dans les
meilleures dispositions possies donc
l'avis sera un avis favorable merci la
présidente avis du gouvernement madame
la ministre merci monsieur le président
madame la sénatrice la création d'une
commission de concertation entre maire
bailleur et réservataire était une
proposition qui figurait dans un de nos
amendements le 12 du gouvernement bon
dont nous regrettons qu'il ait pas été
voté cependant pour des questions de
rédaction nous émettons un avis de
sagesse à votre
amendement
merci madame la ministre je suis saisie
d'une demande d'explication de vote de
collègue Amel
gquier merci monsieur le Président
Madame la rapporteur je voudrais
évidemment saluer on a eu l'occasion
d'en parler hein cette volonté de mettre
en place des instances supplémentaires
de concertation d'explication de
présentation maintenant je je reste sur
sur ma position et sur cette ligne que
l'on se pose qui est de simple au
maximum et ne pas rajouter de commission
au commission sachant que ces pratiques
existent déjà cette pratique existe déjà
encore une fois il s'agit pas de refuser
et je comprends et je salue mais pour
une cohérence encore une fois avec les
messages que nous tenons notamment avec
nos élus locaux nous ne voterons pas cet
amendement merci chers collègues ah il
y d'accord très bien je vais donc s'il
n'y a pas d'autres demande d'explication
de vote mettre au voie cet amendement
numéro 8 qui a euh reçu un avis
favorable de la commission madame la
Présidente et un avis de sagesse madame
la ministre je mets donc au voix qui est
favorable à et pour cet
amendement qui est
contre qui
s'abstient il est
adopté amendement numéro
10 rectifié terre madame Noël merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues dans un souci de
parallélisme des formes le présent
amendement prévoit qu'en absence d'une
qu'en présence pardon d'une convention
intercommunale d'attribution la
commission d'attribution serait composée
notamment du président de leepci des
maires de chaque commune membre et
présidé par le président de le PCI qui
aurait une voix prépondérante en cas
d'égalité des voix je vous remercie
merci merci avis de la commission madame
la
Présidente chers collègues si
effectivement je peux souscrire à à
l'idée que vous avez dans cet amendement
qui est de confier la présidence de la
caléole lorsqu'elle est intercommunale à
l'EPCI c'est pas du tout illogique au
contraire on a déjà prévu de le faire en
qualité de président de d'une convention
intercommunale d'attribution sauf que là
vous excluez de fait dans la rédaction
de l'amendement je sais que ce n'est pas
ce que vous avez voulu faire chers
collègues mais et vous excluez de fait à
travers la rédaction de votre amendement
que puisse participer à la composition
de la commission à la fois le bailleur
social l'État et les membres qui ont une
voix consultative c'est la raison pour
laquelle je donne un avis défavorable au
regard de la rédaction telle que votre
amendement et proposé
aujourd'hui merci avis du gouvernement
madame la ministre merci monsieur le
président madame la sénatrice Noël
actuellement les EPCI sont tenus
d'élaborer une CIA qui peuvent ils
peuvent demander la création d'une
caléole intercommunale et leur président
ou leur représentant est membre de cette
caléole le présent amendement propose de
leur confier la présidence de la de
cette caléole mais cette proposition est
déjà satisfaite par le texte qui a été
voté en commission des Affaires
économique dès lors que le PCI fait la
demande d'une caléole réunie à son
échelle en outre le présent amendement
supprimerait la possibilité pour les
EPCI qui disposent d'une CIA de
conserver des caléoles communales ou
intercommunales avec un périmètre qui ne
serait pas celui de le PCI pour ces
raisons le Gouvernement est ém un avis
défavorable
merci Madame la Ministre madame Noël
vous maintenez vous retirez votre
amendement très
bien passons à
l'article 14 qui est présenté par le
gouvernement madame la
ministre article 14 amendement 14
merci monsieur le Président donc notre
amendement 14 précise comment la caléole
doit motiver ses décisions négatives en
distinguant le cas des refus
d'attribution et le cas des décisions de
nonattribution aux candidats proposés
par les réservataires la caléol doit
assurer la transparence sur toutes ces
décisions transparence pour les
demandeurs qui voient refuser un
logement et radier de la liste des
demandeurs transparence au réservataire
lorsque sans que le dossier du candidat
proposé ne soit rejeté sa demande radiée
elle décide de ne pas suivre la
proposition effectuée par un
réservataire cette
transparence permettra en outre au
réservataire de mieux comprendre la
politique de la caléole et d'adapter ses
propositions en conséquence enfin
certaines décisions de nonattribution
peuvent être incomprises ou leur
légitimité contestée et les réservateurs
peuvent souhaiter en parler dans les
instances prévues à cet effet fait avec
l'ensemble des bailleurs et des élus
c'est la raison pour laquelle il est
précisé dans la proposition que la
contestation des décision peut-être
porté devant les commissions de
concertation prévues par les CIA les
conventions intercommunales
d'attribution en application du
l441-1-6 donc tel est l'objet de notre
amendement proposé par le
gouvernement merci Madame la Ministre
madame la Présidente de la
commission alors madame la ministre il
fallait attendre la fin de la discussion
pour qu'effectivement sur un amendement
du Gouvernement je vous donne un avis
favorable puisque dans cet amendement il
y a des précisions qui sont les bienvenu
concernant les conséquences juridiques
différentes d'un rejet d'une demande qui
entraîne de fait sa radiation ou d'un
refus d'attribution qui n'a pas du tout
les mêmes conséquences puisque le
demandeur peut tout à fait se voir
attribuer un autre logement donc c'est
important de pouvoir afficher cette
transparence et exp plus clairement les
responsabilités en la matière du
président de la Caléo et de la portée de
du vetau du maire qui conduira un refus
d'attribution parce que quand même la
plupart du temps le vetau du maire sera
motivé et conduira un refus
d'attribution et non pas un rejet ce qui
veut dire que ça n'amènera pas à une
radiation mais plutôt simplement à faire
en sorte que le demandeur de logement
social aura toujours sa demande qui sera
valide et qui pourra être proposé sur un
autre logement donc l'avis est favorable
à votre amendement
merci madame la
Présidente je vais donc
mettre au vote cet amendement numéro 14
avec un avis favorable de la commission
je mets au vote qui est
pour qui est
contre qui
s'abstient il est adopté je vais mettre
au voix l'ensemble
de la proposition de loi il y a-t-il des
demandes d'explication de vote monsieur
le
mooine merci beaucoup monsieur le le
président au terme de de l'examen de de
la proposition de loi je dois dire qu'à
titre personnel je je la voterai je
trouve que par rapport à la proposition
de loi initiale de notre collègue un
certain nombre de correctifs ont été
apportés en commission dans l'hémicycle
et qui me semble aller dans le bon sens
j'ai eu par le passé cette casquette
également de de président de de bailleur
social et avec des cales qui sont
largement d'un niveau au-delà du niveau
communal avec parfois regroupant 30 40
50 70 80 communes et il me semblait que
le dispositif iniiciale était peut-être
un peu lourd de ce point de vue-là dans
la vie quotidienne de ces organismes et
et pour autant je suis naturellement
très sensible et très engagé pour que le
chix du président de la République de
renforcer le rôle des maire dans
l'attribution de ses logements puissent
devenir effectif et et donc je je salue
le le travail qui a été conduit qui
pourra sûrement être parachevé
complété peut-être un petit peu amodié
puisque je crois que si le veto est un
un dispositif encore une fois qui qui
qui est préférable peut-être à ce qui
était proposé initialement dans dans la
proposition de loi peut-être que les
pistes que le gouvernement a mis sur la
table peut-être d'encadrement ici et là
mérit d'être de continu être regardé
mais voilà le sens de la démarche en
tous les cas est utile est intéressant
et c'est la raison pour laquelle à titre
personnel je voterai ce texte merci
Monsieur
ravier merci monsieur le Président
l'État impose via la loi su des cotas
mathématiques et brutaux de logements
sociaux souvent inatigniables dans les
communes qui se trouvent financièrement
sanctionné dans les bougurones 50 % des
communes sont carencés rendez-vous
compte de l'absurdité les maires ne
maîtrisent donc pas la politique de
logement de leur commune je voudrais
d'ailleurs vous mettre en garde mes
chers collègues et à travers vous
l'ensemble des maires deux
parlementaires de la majorité
présidentielle ont remis au mois de mai
un rapport au ministre de l'Intérieur
préconisant je le cite d'imposer aux
communes l'attribution d'un nombre de
logements en faveur des demandeurs
d'asile et d'aménager la loi SRU pour
inciter les collectivités territoriales
à favoriser l'implantation sur leur
territoire de lieu d'accueil des demande
d'asile outre son caractère
immigrationniste forcené qui relève de
la provocation envers nos compatriotes
qui n'arrivent pas à se loger de Tell
mesure serait une nouvelle atteinte aux
libertés communales il faut donc cesser
cet étatisme outrancier qui de plus
instaure une préférence voire une
exclusivité étrangère au logement le
pouvoir grandissant des
intercommunalités devient également une
source de dépossession des maires en
matière d'attribution de logements
sociaux ils perdent toute autonomie de
gestion il ils doivent à minima pouvoir
maîtriser la politique de peuplement des
logements sociaux de leur commune le
maire est le premier responsable local
élu pour garantir l'équilibre de sa
commune et son avenir c'est pourquoi je
voterai cette proposition de loi visant
à faire du maire le président de la
commission d'attribution des logements
sociaux et d'examen de l'occupation des
logements et renforçant la
représentation de la commune en son sein
par la présence de six conseillers
municipaux merci Monsieur
salmon
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues bien
entendu les élus municipaux connaissent
leur territoire ils connaissent les
immeubles de leur communes ils
connaissent même parfois certaines
caches
d'escalier ça c'est une réalité mais
nous nous préférons la décision
collégiale parce que elle est pour nous
garante de plus d'équité et de s'appuyer
sur des vrais critères objectivables la
décision jupitérienne ne nous satisfait
jamais nous avons souvent dans cet
hémicycle des propositions de loi nous
les chiffferons souvent pour éviter des
dérives dans un cas ou un autre et bien
là j'ai l'impression qu'avec cette
proposition de loi nous organisons des
potentiels
dérives des potentiels dérives je ne dis
pas parce qu'on fait beaucoup de
raccourcis parfois ici que il y aura
elles seront massives mais il y aura des
dérives c'est certain la la catastrophe
sur le logement la crise du logement
c'est une catastrophe annoncée comme
beaucoup d'autres catastrophes mais le
gouvernement n'a fait que l'empirer la
vraie question c'est cette pénurie de
logement et je pense que cette
proposition de loi et j'en suis certain
n'apporte aucune solution pas plus en
terme de sécurité publque que en terme
de pénuriie de logements
sociaux merci monsieur
oui merci Monsieur le monsieur le
Président comme j'ai pu le dire donc en
discussion générale nous sommes
favorables à redonner donc des pouvoirs
aux élus locaux dans la commission
d'attribution et nous sommes donc
favorables à ce que le nombre de
conseillers municipaux soit plus
nombreux si ce n'est que voilà dans
l'organisation de ces commissions et la
présence
donc régulièrement de d'autant de
conseillers municipaux va je pense poser
quelques difficultés
d'organisation après sur le droit de vet
qui a fait l'objet de d'un débat dansun
notre
groupe je l'ai j'ai pu l'exprimer bien
sûr il faut partir sur le principe que
tous les maires sont
intègres pas de souci mais comme j'ai pu
le dire on sait très bien que c'est pas
la réalité sur les territoires et qu' a
certains maires qui me semble-t-il nous
semble-t-il risque d'abuser de ce droit
de véau donc dans ces conditions notre
groupe
s'abtiendra merci madame la Présidente
Sophie
prima président merci monsieur le
Président je voudrais d'abord en
introduction remercier de nouveau la
rapporteur et Madame la Ministre j'ai un
petit peu été bruyante de temps en temps
Madame le Ministre pendant vos
interventions mais si vous n'y voyez que
que la que voilà la la la fougue voilà
de ceux qui essayent de de représenter
euh nos nos maires et les difficultés
auxquelles ils sont ils sont confrontés
je ne vais pas redire ici ce que n'était
pas la PPL je je me suis exprimé
longuement sur ce sujet et non mes chers
collègues cette PPL ne va pas résoudre
le problème grave du logement qui est le
problème de la construction de
l'incitation à construire que ça soit du
logement social ou du logement tout
court donc je ne pas redire tout ça mais
évidemment cette PPL ne va pas résoudre
cela je voudrais dire également euh à à
nos collègues qui ont peur de la
décision verticale euh de du maire mais
jamais un maire ne prend une décision
tout seul jamais il a travaillé avec ses
services sociaux il a travaillé avec son
adjoint au social il a travaillé avec
les autres avec le bailleur avec l'État
jamais un maire dit arrive dans un
bureau et dit c'est à lui que je vais
donner ce ce ce ce logement-l c'est fini
ça alors c'était peut-être des pratiques
d'un autre temps mais c'est terminé
jamais un maire ne travaille tout seul
et donc le poids de l'importance non pas
du maire mais de l'équipe municipale
communale me semble être un élément
extrêmement important et puis je
voudrais dire à à Pierre salvoldelli euh
que effectivement j'ai pas parlé de
demandeur de logement mais je vous ai
parlé des gens je vous ai parlé des de
ces gens qui viennent chez moi dans
l'ouest de le le far ouest des Yvelines
et qui vont travailler à H sous bois 2h
de transport pour y aller 2hur pour
revenir non non c'est pas du pipo je
peux vous donner presque leur nom parce
que comme c'est pas anonymisé je les
connais et comme je les rencontre et qui
viennent dans mon bureau pour me
supplier d'avoir un logement à hnaet
sousbois je peux vous dire qui c'est des
des des personnes comme ça dont les
enfants sont perdus parce qu'ils ont
perdu leurs repère à l'école parce que
les parents font 2h 2 heur d'aller 2h
retour j'en ai plein mon quartier chez
moi donc c'est ça qu'on veut éviter
c'est de permettre l'intégration de
toutes les populations y compris les
plus modestes dans notre commune donc je
n'ai pas parlé de demandeur de demandeur
de logement j'ai parlé effectivement des
gens et de leur réalités et de leurs
difficultés voilà c'est l'objectif merci
beaucoup non non non non merci c'est pas
un Pipo merci beaucoup pour ce débat en
tout cas qui est intéressant et qui
montre à quel point ce sujet est un
sujet d'ampleur merci Monsieur
Guay merci Monsieur le présidentadame
ministre mes chers collègues vous
connaissez l'attachement de notre groupe
à la commune et à donné euh du pouvoir
aux élus et notamment au ma mais euh un
pouvoir sans moyen c'est comme une
voiture sans essence vous pouvez vous
mettre au volant vous tournerz le volant
mais vous avancerez pas d'un mtre mais
c'est exactement la même chose là vous
allez organiser la pénurie ou la gestion
de la pénurie pardonnez-moi la gestion
de la pénurie de logement c'est ça la
question et la question fondamentale que
nous allons et Pascal l'a redit tout à
l'heure et nous vous l'avons redit dans
un certain nombre
d'interventions c'est la question du
budget maintenant est-ce que nous
redonnons les moyens au bailleurs de
construire du logement ou de Renou du
logement et est-ce que oui ou non nous
allons leur redonner les 10 milliards
d'euros qui ont été volés en 6 ans par
le pouvoir MACR voilà la seule question
et à partir de là si on se met en action
et qu'on construit du logement
massivement là on a un autre débat c'est
qu'on norganise pas la peénnerie
ou la gestion de la
pénnerie on peut commencer à répondre
aux besoins des populations aux besoins
des demandeurs et donc le maire lui là
dedans il a une place parce qu'il est
acteur de la réponse à nos concitoyens
et concitoyennes donc pour nous vous
l'aurez compris cette proposition elle
tape un peu à côté puis après on a un
débat de fond où on est fondamentalement
en désaccord sur le droit de véau et
puis sur la question du logement ne9uf
qui va exclure de fait un certain nombre
de publics et notamment les publics les
plus précaires même si c'est sur la
première attribution mais comme
maintenant de plus en plus on quitte de
plus en plus tard son logement social ne
pas permettre à tous les publics de voir
accès au logement neuf va encore plus
les panaliser dans leur parcours donc
pour toutes ces raisons nous voterons
contre ce texte merci Monsieur
jade merci
merci juste juste qu'nait pas ce débat
entre
nous au fond de la loi nationale contre
les
mir partout sur nos territoires et j'en
suis convaincu les maires travaillent au
mieux
à gérer les problèmes de leurs
concitoyens et à faire en sorte que tout
se passe pour le mieux mais il y a aussi
des maires et parmi les maires les plus
actifs sur la construction et
l'attribution de logements sociaux qui
trouve que justement le système de
gouvernance actuel est le bon système
pas parce que ça
contraint leur
mais parce que justement il considère
que se donner à ce moment-là le pouvoir
du droit de véto n'est pas un levier
pour améliorer l'attribution des
logements sociaux et donc n'ayons pas
entre nous un débat des maires contre le
reste du monde c'est un débat sur la
gouvernance dans l'attribution des
logements sociaux et nous verrons et
j'espère et j'espère que dans les débats
que nous aurons que ce soit sur le
budget ou sur le reste nous donnerons
ici dans cette assemblée les moyens à la
construction et à l'attribution des
logents sociaux en masse merci merci
Madame Artigalas
oui monsieur le Président merci oui nous
allons comme je l'ai dit lors de la
discussion générale et les débats n'ont
pas modifié notre avis nous allons bien
sûr ne pas voter cette proposition de
loi comme l'a dit notre mon collègue
Fabien Guay c'est surtout ce droit de
vetau mais aussi la réservation des
logements sociaux nous nous sommes plus
pour ce travail en concertation en amont
des outils ex existent déjà ils peuvent
être améliorés ils peuvent être
développés il faut qu'on travaille bien
évidemment sur cette concertation et les
maires doivent être associé à cette
concertation en amont bien évidemment
des des des commissions d'attribution
euh mais ce cette prpdl l'aura au moins
eu un avantage c'est de montrer que nous
sommes tous d'accord sur ce constat sur
le logement le logement nous le disons
sur ces bans depuis sur tous les bans du
Sénat depuis 6 ans sont
est une bombe sociale on voit bien
toutes les limites là qu'il y a eu à
cette réduction des crédits à tout ce
qui a été fait contre les bailleurs
sociaux la RLS qui a fait la baisse des
constructions de logements sociaux enfin
tout ce travail que nous avons dénoncé
qui a été fait par le gouvernement et
c'est dit moi fa bien j'étais plus sur
11 milliards d'euros hein que 10
milliards mais bon je crois que là
vraiment on est sur une des ponctions
permanentes depuis 6 ans sur le logement
social qui font que on en arrive là à ce
en ce moment effectivement cette loi va
pas résoudre les problèmes et je crois
qu'il sera important que nous ayons un
vrai débat sur le logement madame la
ministre vous le ferez passer au
ministre du logement où nous regrettons
qu'il ne soit pas là aujourd'hui encore
une fois pour le premier débat qu'il y a
à l'Assemblée au Sénat sur ce sujet si
important le ministre n'est pas là nous
le regrettons mais je crois que vraiment
il faudra queil vienne s'expliquer sur
sa vision du logement très rapidement
devant notre assemblée merci madame
gaker monsieur le Président Madame la
rapporteur je vais être très brève juste
pour dire que nous voterons avec
enthousiasme cette proposition de loi
merci beaucoup bravo je suis ravie que
ce soit le premier texte qui soit
aujourd'hui qui soit à l'ordre du jour
parce que j'ai en tête je sors d'une
campagne électorale comme beaucoup
d'entre vous ici et s'il y a bien un
message qu'on nous a fait passer c'est
de redonner aux maires aux élus le
pouvoir d'agir donc merci et bravo
mesdames merci à
tous merci madame la Présidente de la
Commission alors à mon tour pour
terminer ces débat je veux bien sûr
remercier très sincèrement notre
collègue Sophie prima d'avoir été
l'auteur de cette proposition de loi et
et dire combien je remercie également le
président du groupe les républicains
Bruno rotillot de l'avoir inscrite en
priorité dès l'ouverture et la reprise
de nos travaux parlementaire cela montre
l'intérêt de la droite et du centre mais
je crois aussi pouvoir dire de
l'ensemble des travaers de cette
hémicycle pour la question du logement
nous n'avons cessé depuis un certain
nombre d'années de dire que le logement
était la priorité numéro 1 mais que
malheureusement c'était pas la priorité
pour le gouvernement en tout cas ça de
n'a jamais été depuis 2017 qu'Emmanuel
Macron est arrivé à l'Élysée et on le
voit nous avons été les premiers ici à
dénoncer au Sénat la ponction qui a été
faite sur les bailleurs sociaux à
travers la RLS bien évidemment on ne
pouvait pas la rétablir dans le projet
loit de finance parce que c'était
article 40 enfin demander à ce qu'elle
soit supprimée mais pour autant on a
demandé à plusieurs reprises qu'il y ait
une clause de revoyure clause de
revoyure qui n'est jamais arrivée et on
savait pertinemment que la RLS aller se
transformer en quelque chose de
définitif et nos inquiétudes
malheureusement ont été avérées nous
avons aussi amendement à prè amendement
demander la baisse de la TVA au taux de
5,5 % alors quand vous dites on attend
de voir la droite ce qu'elle va faire
dans le projet de loit de finance je
crois que vous avez déjà vu ce que la
droite a été capable de faire au cours
des discussions précédentes je crois
qu'on a été capable de dénoncer les
coupes clairs du gouvernement plus
particulièrement sur le monde du
logement social et sur les bailleurs
sociaux leur réduisant toute leur
capacité d'autofinancement mais au-delà
de ça nous considérons qu'aujourd'hui le
logement doit être examiné dans sa
totalité sur toute la chaî du logement
on a eu précédemment un débat sur
l'accession à la propriété mais il
faudra aussi un jour parler du logement
privé comment est-ce qu'on donne un
véritable statut du bailleur privé pour
qu'il y ait un rendement à travers le
logement locatif
privé merci merci madame la Présidente
mes chers collègues donc mettre au voix
l'ensemble de la proposition de loi
visant à renforcer le rôle des maires
dans l'attribution des logements sociaux
qui est
pour qui est
contre qui
s'abstient il est adopté je vais
suspendre la séance quelques instants la
séance est
suspendue